.
So, ich bin am Start.
Ich weiß ernsthaft nicht, warum ich da gerade Wordpad für den Text aufgemacht hab.
Brauchst du unbedingt RGB? Nee.
Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Ich hab überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn das nicht RGB ist.
Ich mache RGB meistens aus.
Wobei, ich sagen muss... Warte mal, ich mach mal Kirby ein bisschen leiser.
Ja, wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin jetzt auch nicht total abgeneigt, wenn die RGB hat.
Weil die K95, die hat auch RGB und ich hab die lange Zeit ausgehabt.
Und jetzt hab ich's einfach an, sodass es leicht blau, gelb so rum vor sich hin wavet.
Das Keyboard, das hatte ich mir schon vor einer Weile angeguckt.
Das hat mir nicht gefallen, weil's glaub ich kein Num Block hatte, oder?
Num Block. Ich will Num Block. Num Block.
Ich will Num Block haben. Okay.
Das hatte ich mir vor einer Weile schon mal angeguckt und dann hab ich mir eine Ducky One Skyline bestellt und...
Guck mal, hier mit dem Knopf oben dran.
Eine Ducky One Skyline für die Arbeit bestellt und ich hab mir für die Heimat eine K95 Platinum bestellt.
Gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Muss ja nicht durchgehend Rainbow geplinkt sein. Ja, genau.
Weil so ein bisschen RGB ist schon nicht verkehrt.
So, mal Kirby mal kurz ein bisschen. Wir machen jetzt entspannende Nintendo-Musik-Wintermix.
Das ist Secret of Mana, das hör ich sofort.
Warum ist der Sound so laut eigentlich gerade?
Ah, so.
Jetzt ist der Sound ein bisschen leiser.
Dann einfach so.
So ist gut.
Ja Leute, also ich muss euch ja mal erzählen wegen der Tastatur, ne?
Das war gestern, nachdem ich den Stream ausgemacht hab. Ich hab hier immer so eine große 05er-Klasse.
Das ist eigentlich das 05er Plastikbecher. Oh, Plastik.
Die Umwelt, ich hab Plastikbecher.
Also ich hab hier so ein 05er Plastikbecher stehen und da hab ich immer ganz Noob-Style Wasser mit ein bisschen Orangensaft drin.
Hier, Leute. Exzellent.
Exquisite. Wasser mit Orangensaft, ja.
So, und die Sache ist die, ich hab...
Ich bin dann irgendwie ein bisschen rumgelaufen, hab was getrunken, beim abstellen hab ich halt ein bisschen gesaut.
Nicht viel, nicht viel.
Du hast dir letztens Nudelsuppe auf die Tastatur gekippt.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das ist schlecht.
Wobei, ja, es ist schlecht, aber Hauptsache, Hauptsache schön trocknen lassen, alles.
Na ja, zumindest nachdem ich dann erstmal geistesgegenwärtig mit quasi Overwatch-Top-500-Reflexes
hab ich dann quasi erstmal Lappen auf die Tastatur geschmissen.
Und...
Dann hat auch alles wieder funktioniert. Das Einzige, was passiert ist, ist die RGB-Beleuchtung ist instant ausgegangen.
Aber ich hab's dann mal abgestöpselt, wieder eingestöpselt, die Tastatur.
Und dann ging's auch wieder.
So, und was ich dann aber festgestellt hab, ist...
Also bei der hier jetzt.
Was ich dann festgestellt hab, ist, die Q-Taste ging nicht.
Aber ihr seht, Q geht wieder.
Und gestern Abend, als ich den Rechner da ausgemacht hab, hab ich mir gedacht,
hoffentlich ist die Tastatur kaputt.
Weil da kann ich mir was Neues kaufen.
Weil ich mag die Tastatur nicht.
Und leider, wie ihr seht, geht das Q wieder.
Aber ich hab jetzt festgestellt, manch andere Taste klebt ein bisschen, dank dem Orangensaft.
So, und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich hab jetzt die Auswahl.
Ich könnte das sauber machen.
Oder aber ich könnte mir eine neue Tastatur kaufen, weil ich die Tastatur eh kacke finde.
Also mal zur Erklärung, das haben wir auf Twitter auch. Ich hab's ja auf Twitter geschrieben im Endeffekt.
Also was mir an der Tastatur nicht gefällt, ist folgendes.
Erstens, dass die schon seit fast Anfang an doppelte Tastenanschläge hat, das macht mich verrückt.
Ja, Maximilianos erzähl ich gerade, weil das haben viele gefragt.
Ich bin nicht der Einzige, der das wissen wollte.
Also das ist das Erste, dass sie fast seit Anfang an doppelte Tastaturanschläge hat.
Das macht mich echt verrückt.
Wenn du irgendwas copy und pastest und auf einmal ist es dreimal drin und sowas.
Ihr habt's im Stream schon öfters gesehen.
Und kann man RMA'en? Ja, hab ich ja nicht gemacht.
Ich glaube jetzt mit Orangensaft kann ich sie nicht mehr RMA'en.
Ups, wollte da gar nicht die IP oben rein machen.
So, das nächste ist, was mir auch nicht gefällt, dass sie ein komisches Layout hat.
Das muss ich jetzt ein bisschen erklären.
Auf Twitter kann man das immer so schlecht erklären.
Man macht nicht so viel Zeichen und das auch gut.
Das macht der Twitter aus.
Die haben meine Rahmen-Tastatur auch eher im Art.
Ernsthaft, ich will die Tastatur aber eigentlich gar nicht mehr,
weil die gefällt mir auch aus anderen Aspekten nicht.
Mir gefällt das Layout nicht.
Und zwar, das ist auch ein Problem.
Was ich seit Anfang an hatte, haben wir mal ein schönes Bild von der Tastatur.
So richtig schön in groß vielleicht.
Und zwar, von Anfang an hatte ich das Problem.
Ah, hier sieht man es gut.
Und ich dachte mir, ich komme damit irgendwie klar.
Das Problem, was ich mit dem Layout habe,
ich meine jetzt nicht, dass es eine Quertz-Tastatur ist,
oder in dem Fall die englische Variante.
Ne, was mir nicht gefällt an der Tastatur ist,
das Control, also Steuerung und der G6-Macro-Key, die liegen so komisch beieinander,
dass man nie auf die Schnelle,
ich meine ja, die haben ein bisschen andere Texturierungen,
es ist nicht so, dass man das gar nicht merken würde,
aber ich bin nicht in der Lage, das schnell zuzuahnen.
Gibt es noch mal ein richtig großes Bild?
Ja, sehr schön von oben.
Da kann man nämlich ein bisschen ranzoomen.
Genau.
Guck, ihr seht, die haben ja schon andere Textur auf den Buttons,
aber man merkt das nicht.
Man merkt das nicht, doch hat sie.
Aber man merkt das nicht richtig.
Dementsprechend, ich habe das so gefühlsmäßig drinne,
dass ich meine Control-Taste am unteren, bzw. am linken Rand,
wo die Keys aufhören, suche.
Und ich will nicht wissen, wie oft ich auf G6 gedrückt habe,
anstatt auf Control.
Die Textur ist zwar ein bisschen anders,
aber ganz ehrlich, Leute, wenn ihr irgendwas macht in einem Game,
hier ihr schöner AD-Spam oder sowas,
und dann wollt ihr einfach irgendwie in Deckung gehen,
irgendwie Control-Spam, und ey, ich habe gedacht,
ich gewöhne mich da dran, aber ich hatte,
ich habe mich nie hundertprozentig dran gewöhnt.
Einfach G6 auf Control-Rampen, ja, könnte man auch,
aber das ist auch keine wirklich gute Lösung,
weil ich dann öfters auch mal mit dem Finger hier dazwischen lande.
Ich bin auch noch so ein Noob, der den kleinen Finger
für Control verwendet, ja.
Ich lande auch öfters dazwischen.
Das Nächste ist, dass die Tasten keine schöne Oberfläche haben.
Die sind sehr rutschig.
Die sind einfach halt, die sind nicht nur glatt,
die sind so poliert glatt.
Ich kann dir die hier empfehlen.
Erstmal Amazon Ref Link, GG.
Ich gucke mir erst mal das Zimmer an. Chakun RGB.
Weiß nicht.
Zu günstig.
Unter 200 Euro geht nichts.
Nee, weißt du, ich muss, ohne Scheiß,
ich muss erst mal ein bisschen rumgucken.
So, das ist das nächste Problem, dass die Tasten mir zu,
man könnte sagen, zu schlüpfrig sind im Endeffekt.
Meinung zu Forsen Boys.
Ich gucke mir Forsen kaum an, aber die Sachen,
die ich geguckt habe, fand ich nicht schlecht.
Ohne jetzt erklären zu können, warum, ist so ein bisschen,
wie ich gucke auch manchmal Grip,
und ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich Grip gucke.
Wahrscheinlich, weil mein Salzgehalt im Blut
nicht hoch genug ist oder so, keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn ich mir das angucke, dann finde ich es eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ich weiß, Forsen Boys ist, glaube ich, das Reddit von ihm.
Aber das lese ich nicht.
Einziger Discord und auch Memeredit von irgendeinem Twitch-Streamer,
wo ich drauf bin, ist xQc.
Und ich gucke xQc schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr.
Einfach, ich fand den Chat schon immer anstrengend,
aber ich fand den Chat cool anstrengend.
Aber jetzt mittlerweile mit 16.000 Zuschauern,
es passiert auch nichts Lustiges mehr im Chat,
sondern es wird einfach nur hirnlos gespammt, das ist doof.
So, also weiter im Text, was mich an der Tastatur stört.
Wie gesagt, da rutscht öfters mit dem Finger rein
und die Tasten sind mir zu schlüpfrig im Endeffekt.
Dazu kommt, dass die Tasten für meinen Geschmack
nicht fest genug sind.
Titan Toast gucke ich mir gleich auch nochmal an.
Das ist ja der Klassiker, die Cherry Tastatur.
Das ist eine mit flachen Tasten, oder? Flache Tasten kann ich gar nicht.
Da komme ich nicht mit klar.
Oder sieht das auf dem Bild nur so aus.
Dazu kommt, dass die Tasten für meinen Geschmack
ein bisschen viel Spielraum haben.
Ich meine, Tasten, egal bei welcher Tastatur,
sind die Tasten ja im Endeffekt immer nur draufgesteckt.
Das ist ja logisch.
Ich meine, du hast unten drunter, was auch immer,
Rubber Daumen oder irgendwelche mechanischen Geschichten,
sei es jetzt diese Sache hier oder sei es irgendwie,
wie heißt das andere, Bucket, Nee, Spring, Wackelt,
Spring oder so, das alte IBM-Zeug ist im Prinzip egal.
Aber klar, die Tasten sind alle nur aufgesteckt.
Aber ich finde, hier haben sogar die Tastaturen, die wackeln.
Also sprich, ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen,
also sie wackeln für meinen Geschmack zu viel,
dass sie ein bisschen wackeln ist okay.
Ich zeige euch mal was, ich habe jetzt die Hand auf WASD,
wenn ich jetzt hin und her wackele mit meinem Finger,
also quasi das, was man halt macht,
wenn man gerade rum eidelt und wartet,
dass was passiert und man nichts tun will.
Hört mal hin.
Die wackeln mir ein bisschen viel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt gehört hat.
Das ist natürlich viel mehr als bei anderen Tastaturen,
aber es ist gefühlt mehr und es ist...
Ach, man hört es nicht.
Wegen meiner Noise-Gate hört man das nicht.
Wartet mal.
Klar, kann man gar nicht hören.
Ich muss mal Noise-Gate ausmachen.
Filters, Noise-Gate.
Okay, vielleicht hört man es jetzt.
Hat man es jetzt gehört?
Naja, gut, was auch immer.
Ich habe jetzt einfach die Finger auf WASD gehabt
und habe die Finger hin und her gewackelt,
nicht die Tasten.
Und die Tasten wackeln halt mit den Fingern so weit hin und her,
dass man das halt so hört.
Noise-Gate.
Gefällt mir auch nicht.
Das sind alles so Punkte, die sind auch recht...
...persönlich von mir.
Also das ist jetzt nichts, wo ich sagen würde,
das ist jetzt für jeden K.O.-Kriterium,
diese Tastatur zu kaufen.
Nee, nee, die Tastatur an sich ist nicht schlecht.
Die hat wirklich viele Features
und an sich ist es eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Tastatur.
Aber nicht für mich.
Das war für mich halt ein totaler Fehlkauf.
Das habe ich noch geschrieben,
da ich jetzt nicht 2x überlegen muss.
Genau, das habe ich ja schon gehabt,
dass man nicht spürt, wo manche Knöpfe sind.
Ah ja, dazu kommt auch noch,
dass auf F und J ist ja so ein Nippel drauf.
Ducky Shine 7 habe ich noch nicht angeschaut,
aber ich habe eine Ducky Skyline auf der Arbeit.
Ich habe es geschafft, von der F-Taste
diesen Erkennungshuppel,
der da oben drauf ist,
so weit durch einfach nur Fingerbewegen oben drauf,
so weit abzunutzen,
dass man in dem Vergleich zum J kaum noch spürt.
Und das ist bei einer 180-Euro-Tastatur
nach ungefähr einem Jahr, oder wann habe ich die gekauft?
Eineinhalb Jahre, Jahr, irgendwie so, ein Jahr.
Ein bisschen länger vielleicht.
Das kann aber eigentlich auch nicht sein,
dass das sich so schnell abnutzt.
Das darf auch nicht sein.
Genau, ein Problem, was ich damit habe, ist,
ich habe das Gefühl, das Ding zieht echt Dreck und Staub an.
Ich dachte am Anfang,
die Tastatur ist ziemlich dreck- und staub-resistent,
weil sie halt nicht so viele Rillen hat
und die Tasten auch relativ offen in der Luft hängen.
Nicht so viele, wie die ollen Rubberdom-Tastaturen,
da sie überall die Krümel rein sind.
Hier ist es anders.
Du kannst theoretisch ohne Probleme hier so einmal durchpusten,
weil die Tasten relativ frei stehen.
Aber trotzdem, das Ding vor allem unten an der Gummiauflage
sammelt sich halt echt viel Staub.
Ich müsste das Ding theoretisch jeden Tag,
nachdem ich da irgendwie fertig bin,
abputzen, dass das schön sauber bleibt.
Das ist keine Gummiauflage, das ist Plastik.
Ja, kann auch sein.
Außerdem fühlt sich die Auflage komisch an.
Wenn ich da mit den Fingern drüber gehe, ist es irgendwie...
Naja, so, und das ist halt recht subjektiv,
aber für mich war das der totale Fehler auf die Tastatur.
Ach ja, und das hier geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Die Software, die dabei ist, ist crap.
Ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen.
Habe ich die überhaupt an?
IQ, ich hoffe, das ist die aktuellste Variante,
und die läuft ja auch hier auf meinem Account
mit ohne Admin-Rechte richtig.
So, ich mache jetzt mal einen Prozess-Explorer an.
Und es passt mal auf.
Die Tastatur-Software, die zieht permanent...
Es ist besser geworden, es ist besser geworden.
Aber ich frage mich, warum muss eine Tastatur-Software
permanent CPU-Leistung ziehen?
Und es ist besser geworden, das waren mal 4-5%
von einem 8700K, wo ich mir gedacht habe, warum?
Was macht die denn?
Ich tippe auf der Tastatur nichts.
Warum zieht die Software überhaupt CPU-Leistung?
Ohne, dass ich sie benutze, ohne, dass sie einfach nur an ist.
Warum?
Das muss doch echt nicht sein.
Die Logitech-Software kriegt das beispielsweise auch
ganz ohne Probleme hin, überhaupt kein Ding.
XD Monty, moin.
Das kann nicht sein.
Und je nach Version ist es mal stärker ausgeprägt,
mal weniger stark ausgeprägt.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, es hängt ein bisschen davon ab,
wie viele Makros und so man drin hat.
Das sollte aber überhaupt nichts ziehen.
Ja, Failure, 2% ist ja richtig krass.
Aber wie gesagt, die hat früher auch mal mehr gezogen.
Die haben das wohl die letzte Version optimiert.
RGB habe ich ja gerade aus.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Hat einfach nur nicht geleuchtet.
Aber das RGB kannst du ja auch komplett ohne die Software anmachen.
Das macht ja die Tastatur eingebaut.
Also, da sind alle so Punkte, wo ich mir denke,
das muss eigentlich nicht sein.
Und deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschlossen,
ich will eine neue Tastatur.
Ohje, heute habe ich ja auf Twitter was gepostet, Leute.
Ich will jetzt aber gar nicht so viel dazu erzählen,
sonst flippen mich auch wieder alle aus.
Ich habe auf Twitter heute gepostet,
dass ich es blöde finde,
dass so viele Leute Sachen verbieten wollen.
Es wurde nämlich heute auf Twitter wieder diskutiert,
ob man nicht Feuerwerk verbieten soll.
So, dann habe ich geschrieben, Leute,
ich mache schon seit Jahren kein Feuerwerk mehr,
aber ich finde den Ansatz blöde,
immer direkt alles verbieten zu wollen,
ohne sich da Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Alter, da haben sich die Leute wieder aufgeregt.
Meine Güte, ey.
Was da wieder gekommen ist, so nach dem Motto,
ich wäre ein Tierquäler,
ich bin Nazi-AfD-Wähler, ich war alles.
Einfach nur, weil ich gesagt habe,
ich finde es blöd,
die Sachen immer direkt zu verbieten.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Die sind mittlerweile so...
Die haben so dünne Haut mittlerweile,
alle Leute, dass alle instant oder viele,
nicht alle, es sind ja nicht alle,
haben ja auch viele draufgeschrieben,
so nach dem Motto, ja, sehen sie anders.
Viele haben ganz normal darauf reagiert.
Aber die sind so dünnhäutig mittlerweile,
die Leute, ey.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich meine, es ist Twitter.
Es ist eine relativ anonyme Plattform im Internet.
Das heißt, weder ich noch der
können uns da irgendetwas, können uns nix.
Also man muss da eigentlich überhaupt keine
Bedenken haben irgendwie.
Das heißt, gerade da könnte man doch ein bisschen
sich die Sache einfach mal anhören.
Wie gesagt, ich muss jetzt so 2, 3 Minuten
mal drauf rumreiten.
Ich mache selbst kein Feuerwerk.
Ich finde, Feuerwerk an Silvester ist eigentlich
eines der unsinnigsten Sachen überhaupt.
Ich wäre von einem Verbot überhaupt nicht betroffen.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich sogar rein die Stille
und dass meine Katze keine Panik bekommt an Silvester.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich sogar gut finden.
Aber was ich nicht gut finde, ist,
dass das Erste, was den Leuten einfällt mittlerweile
immer ist, man soll die Sachen verbieten.
Ich habe auch gar nichts prinzipiell dagegen,
wenn man Sachen verbietet, aber nur,
wenn man sich vorher Gedanken gemacht hat,
was es denn für Möglichkeiten gibt,
die Probleme, die man eben erkannt hat, zu ändern.
Und wenn man sich Gedanken dazu gemacht hat
und danach sagt zu irgendeinem Problem,
uns fällt nichts Gescheites ein,
oder alle Lösungsansätze sind doof,
wir verbieten das, dann lasse ich es mir irgendwie gefallen.
Aber bei allem, was einem irgendwie nicht passt,
gleich schreien zu verbieten.
Was wollen wir als nächstes verbieten?
Nudel essen.
Ich fühle mich auch unglaublich angegriffen dadurch,
dass manche Leute Nudel essen.
Das wird dann immer mehr.
Und das ist das, wo ich meine Bedenken habe.
Mir geht es gar nicht so sehr um Feuerwerk oder sonst irgendwas,
sondern, dass man als Erstes immer auf die Idee kommt,
Sachen verbieten zu wollen.
Weil eins ist klar, meiner Ansicht nach,
wenn das Erste, was einem einfällt, ist,
Sachen zu verbieten, dann besteht überhaupt kein Bedarf mehr,
sich um was Gedanken zu machen.
Das heißt nämlich, automatisch dadurch,
dass man es mit einfach, wir verbieten, gut ist,
Haken drunter, heißt es, man muss sich zu Problemen,
die es gibt, keine Gedanken machen.
Und das ist eigentlich schlecht,
weil keine Gedanken machen heißt auch automatisch,
dass es keine neuen Denkanstöße,
keine neuen Richtungen oder sowas in der Richtung gibt.
Das heißt, wenn man zu allem, was irgendwie Probleme macht,
entweder ignoriert, verbietet oder wegdefiniert,
kommt da im Ende nichts Gescheites bei raus.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das.
Ja, aber, Alter, wie da die Leute abgegangen sind.
Und wisst ihr, was das Highlight,
wisst ihr, was mein absoluter Highlight-Tweet war,
wo einer geschrieben hat, also nicht nur einer,
es haben mehrere Leute geschrieben.
Also, ich kann die Argumentation nicht ganz nachvollziehen.
Hast du dir mal Cool Master Master Keys angeschaut?
Nee, ich schreibe mir das aber mal auf,
ich gucke mir das gleich an.
Also mein Lieblingsargument,
also Argument, weil man das so nennen kann überhaupt,
was einer gebracht hat, war, so sinngemäß,
dann müsste man ja auch Mord erlauben,
weil es schränkt ja sonst die Freiheit ein.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht,
vergleichen die Leute wirklich ernsthaft gerade
Feuerwerk zünden mit Leuten, die andere Leute umbringen?
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, also die Leute sind echt...
Ich weiß, da weißt du, bei so einer Antwort,
weißt du gar nicht, wo du anfangen sollst eigentlich.
Da weißt du gar nicht, wo du anfangen sollst,
was dagegen zu sagen, weil es so absurd ist.
Total, total, wie?
Also allein schon der Gedankensprung ist irgendwie merkwürdig
und was ich den Leuten immer dann gerne sagen würde ist,
so willkommen in der Realität.
Die Welt ist halt nicht schwarz oder weiß.
Das heißt, nur weil du eine Sache erlaubst oder verbietest,
heißt das nicht automatisch,
dass du alles andere auch erlauben oder verbieten müsstest.
Das ist eigentlich relativ logisch.
Na ja, gut.
Ah ja, das können wir jetzt echt wieder drüber auslassen.
Aber ich kann es nicht verstehen.
Und einer hat dann auch geschrieben, so nach dem Motto,
magst du, ich entfolge dir jetzt, obwohl ich dir jahrelang folge?
Weil ich ihm, ja, ich gebe so ein bisschen blöde Antwort geschrieben habe, aber...
Oh Mann, oh Mann, Leute, ich verstehe es nicht.
Du bist Informatiker, was verstehst du von Logik?
Ja, offensichtlich nix.
Ich kann Binary-Logik, aber ich kann definitiv nicht Twitter-Logik.
Aber ich glaube, Twitter-Logik kann keiner.
Ah ja, und was auch toll war...
Ich guck mal, ob ich das jetzt finde.
Alter, guckt euch das mal an, das haben voll viele geliked.
Oder fanden es schlecht.
Ja, was auch toll war, so nach dem Motto, die Leute sagten dem Motto,
oh Gott, wenn Leuten, denen ich lange folge,
wenn die dann quasi immer konservative oder sonst was werden...
Also, solange kann der mir eigentlich noch gar nicht folgen.
Ich würde mich weder als jetzt irgendwie...
Ich würde mich eigentlich als nix, keine wirklich spezielle,
keine wirklich spezielle Richtung einordnen.
Ich würde eher sagen, ich bin zukunftsorientiert.
Ich mach mir Gedanken drüber, wie man Sachen machen könnte,
weil jetzt haben wir die Möglichkeit, Sachen zu beeinflussen.
Weil, guckt euch die Umweltgeschichte an,
wenn es erst mal kurz vor knapp ist, ist immer scheiße, was zu machen.
Es kann doch für alle nur von Vorteil sein,
und das ist das, was ich aktuell noch nicht so ganz verstehe,
es kann doch eigentlich unterm Strich für alle nur von Vorteil sein,
wenn man rechtzeitig über Probleme miteinander redet.
Das Problem ist aber, es funktioniert nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt nur mal ein Beispiel...
Also, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, es ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel,
wahrgenommen, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde,
Inder und Chinesen haben sich die letzten Jahrzehnte
hauptsächlich vegetarisch ernährt.
Das kann man nachgucken, das ist so.
Guckt euch aber auch mal die asiatische Küche an.
Allerdings, die letzten Jahre, da gibt es auch Statistiken zu,
die letzten Jahre ist der Fleischkonsum vor allem in Indien und China steigt.
Das ist so, das kann man sich nachgucken.
Und da stelle ich mir natürlich die Frage,
wenn vor allem jetzt im Indischen und Asiatischen,
vor allem im Chinesischen Raum, die Leute mehr Fleisch futtern wollen,
wo sollen wir die ganzen Tiere anbauen?
Das Problem ist, dieses Thema kannst du gar nicht ansprechen,
weil als erstes ist jemand getriggert, der sagt,
Max, du hast Inder gesagt, scheiß AfD wähler, scheiß Nazi.
Als nächstes ist der Veganer getriggert, der sagt,
was? Fleisch? Tiere? Piss dich, Alter.
Dabei will ich weder das eine noch das andere sagen.
Ich würde mir einfach nur gerne Gedanken darüber machen,
was könnte man da so machen?
Und ich meine, die werden bestimmt nicht sagen, oder wir auch nicht,
es wird keine der beiden Seiten sagen, so nach dem Motto,
ja, wir verzichten auf irgendwas, das passiert in der Regel nie.
Deswegen muss man sich Gedanken darüber machen.
Zum Beispiel könnte man sagen, was ein Lösungsansatz ist,
wir könnten sagen, okay, wir haben das Problem,
was sich anbahnt, relativ früh erkannt.
Das ist erstmal schon mal gut, wenn man Probleme früh erkennt.
Wir haben das Problem relativ früh erkannt,
jetzt beteiligen wir uns zum Beispiel an der Forschung,
wie man aus Zellen im Labor Fleisch herstellen könnte.
Das wäre ein Lösungsansatz, dass man sagt,
okay, man braucht jetzt, um Fleisch herzustellen,
muss man keine Tiere mehr umbringen,
man braucht gar keine Tiere mehr.
Das finden die Leute aber dann komischerweise auch kacke.
Allem voran irgendwelche Biobauern finden das kacke,
weil man kann ja auch verstehen, leben davon irgendwie.
Warum kann man nicht sagen, okay, wir haben das Problem erkannt,
wir bauen uns quasi ein gewisses Know-how in diesem Bereich auf,
der definitiv wichtig werden wird in Zukunft.
Ob es auf diese Art und Weise passieren wird, keine Ahnung.
Aber das Problem wird über kurz oder lang passieren.
Wenn wir jetzt quasi frühzeitig anfangen würden,
ein gewisses Know-how in dem Bereich aufzubauen,
weil Inder und Chinesen machen das garantiert.
Und vor allem die Chinesen haben ethisch da weniger Probleme als wir
mit irgendwelchen Zellforschungen oder sonst was.
Das juckt die relativ wenig.
Vielleicht ist bis dahin anders, keine Ahnung.
Das heißt, wir könnten uns sogar theoretisch in dem Bereich
ein gewisses Know-how, Wissensvorsprung erarbeiten,
der allen hier eigentlich über lange Zeit nutzen würde.
Weil ich meine, wenn man sich in einem Bereich auskennt,
der dann wirklich wichtig wird,
und man Leute hat, Know-how hat, Technologie hat,
Firmen haben die das Ganze können, das bringt uns natürlich auch was.
Ich meine, wir exportieren jetzt schon viel,
warum soll man nicht auch sowas machen?
Keine Ahnung, aber über sowas kannst du ja nicht reden,
weil sobald du Inder sagst, kommt der erste an,
Scheiß AfD-Wähler Nazi, obwohl er überhaupt nicht gehört hat,
um was es geht, und wenn du sagst Fleisch,
kommt der Vegane an und ist getriggert,
weil du das Wort Fleisch in den Mund genommen hast.
Und da kommt der nächste an und sagt, direkt alles verbieten.
Und das ist eigentlich das, was ich mit meinem Tweet sagen wollte,
dass mir das auf den Sack geht.
Aber die Leute lesen im Endeffekt nur das, was sie lesen wollen,
aus solchen Tweets raus.
Kam auch schon der erste an, der gesagt hat,
ich habe ja auf einen geantwortet zu nach dem Motto,
ja, man liest immer nur das, was man lesen will,
dann kam der erste an und hat gemeint,
Max, das ist eine AfD-Trump-Aussage.
Warte.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Oh, Mann.
Twitter, Alter, Twitter.
Mechanisch oder Rubberdome?
Mechanisch.
Rubberdome nur, wenn es unbedingt leise sein muss.
So, ich habe jetzt den Chat ein bisschen nach meinem Monolog hier.
Ein bisschen den Chat vernachlässigt.
Ja, Patrick, genau, das sagen ja auch manche.
Ist doch wieder witz, ne?
Ähm.
Habe gestern mit meinem Dead-RGB in das Home-Cinema entzählt.
Huge.
Nice.
Kann man hier nicht donaten?
Doch, ich hatte mal einen Donation-Link,
aber bei Steamlabs, die Einplanung für Donation waren kaputt,
da habe ich es weggemacht.
Also, wenn du mich supporten willst,
kannst du Prime-Sub dalassen, was übrigens jeder machen kann.
Es kostet überhaupt nichts.
Bringt euch alle Vorteile und dem Streamer alle Vorteile.
Heißt nicht, dass ihr unbedingt mich subscriben müsst.
Aber natürlich freue ich mich über jeden Sub.
Du kannst mich aber auch natürlich normal abonnieren.
Und das ist auch nicht verpflichtend,
dass es irgendwie automatisch verlängert wird oder so.
Keine Abo-Falle.
Kannst einfach da sein.
Ich freue mich auch über alle Leute, die zugucken, die im Chat sind,
wenn der Chat aktiv ist.
Tribulon sagt, muss sagen,
dass ihm der ganze Kreter-Hype auf den Sack geht.
Auch wenn ich mit dem Thema jetzt anfange,
dann höre ich noch mal auf.
Ja, Mark G-Plays, das ist eh schwierig,
wie man Sachen mittlerweile nennen darf.
Man muss sich mal überlegen,
wie beknackt das eigentlich ist,
dass man überhaupt nicht mehr um Inhalt oder sehr wenig,
sagen wir mal, sehr wenig um Inhalt diskutiert,
sondern dass irgendjemand die nicht korrekten Wörter verwendet.
Wenn du Ausländer sagst, es ist schon mal schlimm.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich,
ich habe meinen Zivildienst gemacht in einer behinderten Werkstatt.
Das hieß so.
Heute hast du schon das Problem, wenn du behinderter sagst.
Heute heißt das besonders.
Das ist jetzt kein Scherz.
So, gleich bin ich mit dem Chat durch.
Ja, Tribulon, hast du recht.
Digitale Entwicklung von Deutschland ist unter anderem genau deswegen auch im Arsch.
Oh, das ist wieder Secret of Mana, oder?
30? Nee, ist es nicht.
Komische Musik.
Okay, Co-Country, besser.
Was für Browser Add-ons benutzt du?
Also hier habe ich aktuell nur drauf UBlock Origin, Dark Reader,
wobei Dark Reader umstritten ist, muss man sagen.
Dark Reader hat ja Zugriff auf die Seiten, muss das Add-on haben,
weil sonst könnte es die Seiten nicht dunkel machen.
Das ist umstritten, aber es ist ein Open Source Projekt,
also meine Bedenken halten sich in Grenzen.
FFZ für Twitch Emotes und ich glaube, das war's, was ich hier habe.
Ah, Lifeserver Extension, das ist, wenn ich was programmiere,
dass der Browser automatisch reloadet.
Und Audio Pick, das habe ich mal vor einer Weile verwendet,
da konnte man einstellen, welches Tap welche Soundkarte verwendet.
Bei mir auf dem anderen Rechner verwende ich auch nicht so wirklich viel mehr.
Aber überlegen, ich glaube, gar nichts Großartiges mehr.
Ich habe noch ein Add-on, das meine Bookmarks in die Nextcloud synkt.
Das ist richtig gut, kann ich allen empfehlen, die sowas suchen.
Hier, Flocus.
Da kannst du hast du einen Add-on, gibst deine Nextcloud-Daten ein
und dann synkt der deine Browser Bookmarks in die Nextcloud.
Und nicht etwa mit einem eigenen Fenster, sondern die native Bookmarks aus dem...
Was ist denn MonkaSpeed?
Sondern die native Bookmarks aus dem Browser.
Ah, das ist sehr praktisch, das kann man nur empfehlen.
Und nach was suchst du genau für eine Tastatur?
Ich suche eine Tastatur, die sich gut eignet zum Spielen und Programmieren.
Also im Prinzip zum Tippen und zum Spielen.
Deswegen kommt für mich keiner dieser IBM-Tastatur nachbaut.
Und mit ordentlicher Makrosoftware.
Deswegen kommt für mich keine IBM-Nachbautastatur in Frage,
weil die haben diese... Wie heißt das?
Buckling-Spring? IBM? Keyboard? Buckling-Spring, genau.
Die haben eine ziemlich schlechte Latency, was das angeht.
Die brauchen eine ganze Weile, bis sie reagiert haben, dass die Taste gedrückt wurde.
Das ist nicht weiter wild, wenn man schreibt.
Das fühlt sich wahrscheinlich sogar gut an.
Aber wenn man hier den Overwatch-AD-AD-AD-Spam macht, dann ist das schlecht.
Was willst du für eine Art von Tastatur?
Format? Linear? Tactilic?
Also ich will auf jeden Fall was mit NumBlock.
Was hast du gegen RubberDome? Nix.
Prinzipiell nichts, außer dass es sich...
Ich hab mich jetzt sowohl auf der Arbeit als auch hier an was mechanisches gewöhnt,
dass mir der Druck der Tasten nicht mehr gefällt.
Und außerdem, vielleicht ist auch nur viel Gefühl dabei.
Also ich hab jetzt da keine Benchmarks gemacht.
Also ist die Reaktionszeit in Spielen auch deutlich angenehmer.
Also wenn du auf einer RubberDome diesen AD-AD-Spam machst,
auf einer RubberDome, dann kriegst du das so schnell gar nicht hin.
Und es fühlt sich wabbelig an.
Also ich will auf jeden Fall NumBlock.
Welche Switche? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich eine Ducky One Skyline mit Braun-Switches.
Schau mal bei Hardware-Dienst, der hat gute Empfehlungen.
Ja, der empfiehlt die K95 Platinium, die ich austauschen will.
Joa, bist du denn, Patrick?
Deine Grafikart ist kaputt. FeelsBadMan.
Ähm, auf der Seite war ich vorher auch schon Candy Keys.
Ähm, ja, die wurde mir auch empfohlen, die hier.
Genau, die hier wurde mir empfohlen, und zwar...
Die hab ich auch ernsthaft überlegt.
Und zwar... Oh, ich hab, glaub ich...
Irgendeine Abwandlung davon wurde mir empfohlen,
wobei die ist halt genau mit dieser Buckling-Spring-Technik,
wo halt Input-Delay relativ hoch ist.
Also ich hätte so eine ganz, gerne stinknormale,
neumodig-mechanische und nicht die kein-IBM-Nachbau.
Was empfehlt ihr für eine Cloud?
Kommt darauf an, für was. Für was brauchst du es denn? G-Stealth.
Die Rocket Ammo 120. Nee.
Aber alles, was ich bisher von Rocket hatte,
hat mich qualitativ nicht überzeugt.
Mit Racer sieht es ähnlich aus.
Okay, Hauptsache RGB.
Das sind runde Tasten unten.
Na, mag ich nicht.
Ich mag keine gewölbten Tasten.
Das ist schon mal nix für mich.
Gewölbte Tasten mag ich nicht.
Schon mal das Keyboard angeschaut?
Ja, hatte ich mir angeschaut für die Arbeit,
bevor ich mir eine Ducky-One-Skyline bestellt hab.
Ich kann dir nicht mal sagen, was genau mir daran nicht gepasst hat.
Aber irgendwas hat mir daran nicht gepasst.
Aber ich guck's mir noch mal an.
Ja, an und so sieht's aus.
Wollte mich nur mal bedanken, dass du mich früher,
als ich 12 bis 16 war, auf den Geschmack
von der Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker gebracht hast.
Und ich jetzt in einem Berufszweig arbeite,
der mir extrem viel Spaß macht.
Und Geldtechnik geht's mir aktuell sehr, sehr gut.
Das ist schön.
Das ist doch mal.
YouTube Videos lohnt sich, wenn man die richtigen Leute guckt.
Viel Glück, und ich YouTube und der L.
Ja, danke schön.
Nice, Monty.
Pock.
Ja, FOMO, genau, eine besondere Werkstatt.
Wurde Ducky schon empfohlen.
Ich hab sogar eine Ducky.
Ich hab eine Ducky auf der Arbeit.
Die ist top.
Ich würde mir die Ducky One Skyline...
Ich würde mir die sogar...
Ich war vorhin kurz davor, mir die gleichen zu bestellen,
die ich auf der Arbeit hab.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich...
Warum ich mir keine Ducky One Skyline
für daheim bestell.
Äh, Moment.
Mit Numblock.
Wie heißt denn das Ding mit Numblock?
Hier, sowas.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich mir keine Ducky
One Skyline bestelle,
für daheim ist, weil ich
gerne eine ordentliche Makro-Software
haben will.
Und die Makro-Funktion mit der Ducky
ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Die hat auf der Rückseite so ein Jumper-Ding,
wo man Makros macht.
Also ich will schon eine komplette Makro-Lösung haben,
die auch erkennen kann, in welchem Fenster ich bin
und sowas. Also das muss was mit Zusatzsoftware sein,
zum Installieren.
Und dann ist er...
...
Das hier ist das Home-Cinema, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Hm, kennen wir nicht so viel drauf.
Zeig mal, was hast denn da am Start?
Marc G. Blaze, zeig mal her.
Das Home-Cinema.
Warum macht man Fotos im Hochformat?
Anne Will.
Anne Will. Na gut. Jeder soll gucken, was er will.
Man erkennt leider nicht allzu viel. Man erkennt hier eine Couch.
Man erkennt, dass du... Was sind das da oben? Sound?
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch Sound.
Ist das ein Fernseher oder ist das ein...
Das ist schon ein Fernseher, oder?
Ja, das ist ein Fernseher.
Ja, nice Sache. Man erkennt leider nicht so viel drauf.
Aber ist bestimmt ein nice Home-Cinema.
Wieso sollte ich meine Bookmarks in die Cloud ballern,
an das du so zwischen verschiedenen Browsern benutzen kannst?
Übrigens geht es nicht um die Cloud, sondern um Nextcloud,
also quasi das, was bei dir gehostet ist.
Irgendjemand hat auch vorhin gefragt, welche Cloud man verwenden soll.
Da habe ich gesagt, für was hat derjenige schon geantwortet?
Irgendwas mit Stealth?
Okay, Anon, einfach nicht schnell sein.
Was für eine Mechanik, die du hast, die du auf der Arbeit hast.
Wie gesagt, eine Ducky One Skyline.
Ich bin ein bisschen hinterher mit dem Chat.
Warte mal, ich muss erst mal wieder runter scrollen.
Igitt.
Five Happy, was ist denn das?
Das sieht ja eklig aus.
Kann man das in groß machen?
Das sieht ja...
Was soll denn das sein?
Willst du mich debaten oder was?
Das ist irgendeine Tastatur für irgendwie ein Geldautomat oder so.
Was soll das sein?
Anon, dann schick mal einen Link zu einem Rabadon, der gut ist.
Ich habe da jetzt selten etwas empfohlen gesehen.
Max, welchen Netzwerkschrank hast du noch mal im Einsatz?
Gar keinen, ich habe ein 19 Zoll Rack.
Kein Netzwerkschrank.
Also Chuck 690, ich komme mit der K95.
Ich habe es ja am Anfang erzählt, K95 Platinium überhaupt nicht klar.
Max, hast du die neue A15? Kannst du dir empfehlen?
Nein, Astro Headset glaube ich mir nicht.
Ah hier, Handy, Backup, täglich und Bilder.
Das ist eine Frage, die haben wahrscheinlich relativ viele.
Wenn jemand fragt, was ist die beste Cloud?
Es könnte ja auch sein, dass du Sachen in der Cloud hosten willst.
Da würde ich mal ganz unbestochen von Microsoft Azure sagen.
Aber für eine normale Cloud, du willst eigentlich keine Cloud, du willst Backups machen.
Also sprich, wenn es dir nicht darum geht, dass es irgendwie Supersynch und Multistand und sowas,
du willst eigentlich dein Handy-Backup hochladen, nimm einfach irgendwas 0850-mäßiges,
je nachdem wie viel Speicherplatz du brauchst.
Wenn du einfach nur Handy-Backup machen willst, nimm Google Drive.
Ich meine, da kriegst du wie viel Gigabyte mittlerweile standardmäßig?
Zehn?
Weiß gar nicht, genug.
In Google Drive gibt es alle möglichen Clients.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr speichern willst, gibt es noch andere Varianten.
Was auch eine Option ist, falls du das machen willst,
du kannst natürlich auch bei dir daheim eine Festplatte hinstellen mit,
ich sag mal, einem Computer dran, das kann ja ein Raspberry sein, das ist egal,
wo du dann jeden Tag süngst, wenn du bei dir im WLAN bist.
Das ist auch eine Option, wenn du sowas machen willst.
Man darf nämlich immer nicht vergessen, die Clouds sind auch nur Computer,
die woanders stehen.
Nutzt du irgendeinen Bookmark-Manager, um bei all den Links und Tabs nichts zu vergessen?
Ja, habe ich doch gerade einen Freund gezeigt hier, den da verwende ich.
Flokus, das ist kein Bookmark-Manager, das ist ein Zynk für Bookmarks.
Ein Zynk für Bookmarks in Nextcloud rein.
Das heißt, man kann das Ganze im Chrome verwenden, man kann das Ganze im Firefox verwenden
und es verwendet die native Bookmarks aus dem jeweiligen Browser.
Und dann braucht man halt eine halbwegs ordentliche Ordnerstruktur.
Jetzt hier habe ich nicht so viel.
Normalerweise habe ich sowas wie Programmieren für die Arbeit
und halt irgendwelche aktuellen Sachen, Musik, Videokram.
Ich habe nicht so viel.
Also ich bin eh nicht, das habt ihr ja mittlerweile mitgekriegt,
ich bin eh nicht der große Organisator, was Sachen angeht mit Tags und Kategorien und sowas.
Deswegen ist für mich immer wichtig, dass wenn ich was verwende,
so wie ein Notizprogramm oder ein Bookmarks oder To Do's oder sowas,
dass es immer eine gute Suchfunktion hat.
Ich kann mir viel einfacher Textschnipsel im Kopf merken, nach denen ich suchen muss,
als die Sachen kategorisieren.
Vielleicht geht es ja noch irgendwem so.
Ich weiß immer, was ich ungefähr geschrieben habe, bloß nicht mehr wo.
Das heißt für mich ist die Suchfunktion das wichtigste und der Rest brauchen wir eigentlich nicht.
Mechanische Tastaturen sind zu laut, sagt peinliche Affe.
Ich habe mir für die Arbeit, weil ich habe wie gesagt Ducky One Skyland auf der Arbeit,
ich habe mir so, so, so, so, so, so Plastikringe gekauft.
Findet man das, wenn man das hier sucht?
Ringe.
Ich habe mir so Gummiringe gekauft und habe es mir,
wenn ich jetzt Gummi suche, finde ich bestimmt irgendwelche Kondome oder so.
Keyboard Gummi.
Sowas, sowas hier habe ich mir da gekauft in der Richtung.
Huge Picture muss man ja mal sagen.
Man hätte das kontrastmäßig nicht besser aufnehmen können, dieses Bild.
Da sind so kleine Plastikringe oder Silikonringe.
Die kann man unter die Tasten machen, wo man besonders hart draufhaut.
Was bei mir hauptsächlich die Leertaste ist und der Enter-Knopf auf dem Lumblock.
Da habe ich das drunter gemacht, dass die Leute auf der Arbeit nicht gar so sehr nerven mit
Einschlagen auf meine Tastatur.
Ducky und Vortex, von Vortex habe ich noch gar nichts gehört.
Vortex Keyboard, zeige ich schon mal her.
Muss ich mir mal angucken.
Programmable Hotkeys.
Naja, ich brauche eigentlich gar keine extra Hotkeys an der Tastatur.
Eigentlich stören die mich fast nur.
Ich brauche aber nur ordentlich programmable Macrosoftware.
Ja, zum Beispiel, was ich machen möchte mit meiner Macrosoftware.
Ich möchte, dass die erkennt, welche Anwendung gerade Fokus hat.
Dass ich andere Sachen einstellen kann.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Dass ich andere Sachen einstellen kann, wenn ich in der Linux VM bin, als wenn ich zum Beispiel in Windows bin.
Übrigens habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich heute mal ein neues Fire HD 8 nicht geflasht, sondern de-amazonifiziert habe.
Und es total einfach gewesen ist.
Was? Was für ein Ding?
Wooting 2 Läcker Edition. Das Ding heißt wirklich so?
Solange es nicht Läcker Edition ist.
Wooting 2 Läcker Edition. Was ist das für ein Name für Tastaturen?
Das ist bestimmt etwas Schwedisches vom Namen her.
Ein extra Gerät für Macros bringt mir nicht wirklich was, es sei denn...
Also ich weiß, dass es so programmable Zwischenstecker gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich will ja eine Macrosoftware, die auch erkennt, welches Fenster Fokus hat und sowas.
Corsair hat keine allzu nice Macrosoftware.
Corsair hat dieses Ding hier, was eigentlich außer langsam sein und Nerven nicht allzu viel kann.
Ich hatte auch keine Schmerzen mit, ein externes Hardware-Tool zu verwenden für Macros.
Dann aber halt mit ordentlicher Macrosoftware, auch mit Betriebssystemintegration.
Wofür brauchst du das Numpad eigentlich?
Das numpad brauche ich einmal zum Zahlen tippen. Ich weiß, Big Brain.
Aber ich brauche das numpad, ehrlich gesagt, hauptsächlich um Enter zu hauen.
Das ist eine meiner häufigsten genutzten Tasten auf der Tastatur.
Numblock Enter. Aber ich tippe gerne längere Nummern auf dem numpad.
Jetzt mal Geisshals in Filter für Macros, gute Frage.
Max ist 5 Kilometer oben im Chat. Jaja, ich komme gerade nicht hinterher.
Da sind zwei Links, ok, zeige ich mal her.
Knits Keyboards, nice.
Jetzt habe ich genug Sachen zum nachgucken.
Ne, ich habe noch keinen Pwner-Gocchi, aber ich habe mir das ernsthaft überlegt.
Der Chat ist immer gerade bei Cloud-Sachen, ich bin echt zu weit hinten dran.
Ich glaube, Flokus unterstützt nichts, außer den Sync von Bookmarks aus Chrome und Firefox.
Warum schreibst du immer eine 1 und löst diese dann? Ah, die Leute haben schon gepostet.
Nein, mit Auto-Hotkey kann man vieles nicht machen.
Außerdem wird Auto-Hotkey von vielen Spielen als Cheat eingestuft.
Ein Beispiel, was du mit Auto-Hotkey nicht machen kannst ist, sende mal Eingaben an eine VM, geht nicht.
Weil Auto-Hotkey auf Windows drauf ist und VM bei irgendeinem Low-Level-USB-Tastatur-Brück oder so verwendet.
Gibt es eigentlich auch Open-Source-Makrosoftware, die man selber auf die Tastatur flaschen kann? Ja, gibt es.
Ich muss die Tastatur unterstützen.
Logitech hat gute Software, das stimmt. Logitech hat meiner Meinung nach die beste Makro- bzw. Verwaltungssoftware.
Leider gefallen mir die Logitech-Tastatur nicht.
Theoretisch würde das auch mit dem Elgato Stream Deck gehen.
Soll ich mit dem Elgato Stream Deck meine Tastatur-Makros machen?
Wo war denn jetzt die Frage?
Muss nicht sein. Muss nicht sein.
Eine TMK- oder QMK-fähige Tastatur.
Ich glaube, das ist diese Custom-Firmware-Geschichte. Muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Muss nicht sein. Ich will einfach eine ordentliche Makro-Software dabei haben.
Ne, die G710 gefällt mir nicht.
Was hast du genau mit dem Amazon Fire HD gemacht?
Ich habe die XDA Fire Toolbox genommen.
Die da. Das ist ein Winners-Programm.
Und habe komplett alles von Amazon runtergeschmissen.
Google Play Store installiert und den Nova-Launcher drauf gemacht.
Und schon ist kaum etwas von Amazon übrig.
Aber ich will das jetzt nicht zu breit treten auf dem Stream, weil wir dürfen nicht vergessen.
Im Endeffekt ist das hier immer noch alles quasi Amazon, wo wir uns gerade hier befinden.
Logitech ist hauptsächlich Lua Zeug. Also die Details.
Das ist das Video mit den Makros.
Make any key a macro. Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Das Gerät habe ich vorher schon mal gesehen.
Das ist so ein Teil, was zwischen das Ding hier, was er da zeigt.
Da, das da. Das stöpselt man zwischen die Tastatur und kann dann quasi eigene Makros mit programmieren.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das das ist, was ich wirklich brauche.
Denn wie gesagt, ich will ja auch erkennen können, ich brauche Betriebssystem-Integration.
Also sprich, meine Makrosoftware soll erkennen können, welches Fenster gerade fokussiert ist.
So, ich bin mit dem Chat gleich, gleich habe ich es geschafft.
Schreibt man schnell in zählen, C++ über Win32, APD macht man nicht.
CB5, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, huge.
Nice.
First time sub.
Max baut seine eigene Hotkey-Software im nächsten Team näher. Das ist leider nicht so einfach.
Zumal das große Problem bei Custom-Software ist. Und auch bei irgendwelchen Low-Level-Keyboard-Hooks und sonstigen Geschichten.
Ich würde das mal ganz gerne als Cheat einstufen.
Hast du dir mal das Happy-Hacking-Keyboard angesündet?
Ich habe jetzt jede Menge Tastatur, die ich mir angucken muss.
Wie kann Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pog, bigprime, bigbrainsub.
Und schreibt alles in der Sampler, alles andere nach Hardware nach.
Was ist Assembler? Hex?
Alles in Hex direkt selbst.
Obcodes raussuchen von Intel und alles im Hex-Editor machen.
Wer benutzt denn bitteschön so plottet Sachen wie Assembler?
Also ich bitte dich.
Okay, ich bin mit dem Chat unten dran, ich hab's geschafft. Ich hab den Chat aufgeholt.
Assembler für Noobs, richtig.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal die Makro-Geschichte an.
Zeig her.
Ja, weniger feiern, mehr zeigen.
Da hab ich immer, ich bin da so ein bisschen misstrauisch, was sowas angeht, wenn es im Endeffekt ja quasi ein Durchschleifer ist für USB.
Also sprich, das Ding tut so, vermute ich mal, dass das Ding so tut gegenüber der Tastatur, als wäre es ein USB-Hub und gegenüber dem Rechner so tut, als wäre es eine USB-Tastatur.
Also quasi so, so, man in the middle USB sozusagen.
Ich vermute einfach mal, dass es so funktioniert, im Detail müssen wir mal gucken.
Da hab ich immer so, so diesen, so dieses, immer im Hinterkopf hätt ich dann das Gefühl, ich hab Input-Lag, weil was dazwischen steckt.
Wahrscheinlich sorgt das überhaupt Null für Input-Lag, aber das ist so Mindgame, wisst ihr.
Ich würd dir jedes Mal denken, ich hab Input-Lag.
Oder ein Keylogger.
Wir werden gebated gerade.
Also muss man sagen, die Leute bei Linus sind absolute Sellout-Profis.
Was, wie wäre es mit diesem Keyboard?
Excellent, das brauch ich.
Da kann man endlich mal ordentlich Binär programmieren.
Excellent, das brauch ich, exquisite Keyboard, das nehm ich.
Ich finde, was ich fast noch besser finde, ist das Control Alt Delete Keyboard für Windows.
Das da, das find ich fast noch besser.
Markus, was hast du gegen die Win32-AP? Nix, was soll ich gegen die Win32-AP haben?
Bildschirmtastatur, genau, das ist die Erklärung.
Das ist geil, Moment, wartet mal.
Das ist gut, das gefällt mir.
Alles markieren, kopieren, einfügen.
So ist es aus.
Vor allem, es passt auch dazu, dass es PS2 ist.
PS2, wahrscheinlich ist es ja noch nicht im Jahr 2000 angekommen.
Okay, auf, jetzt zeigt man hier die tolle Makrofunktion von diesem Ding.
Also ich würde zu dem Pilot sagen GLHF.
Alter, was geht da ab?
Und wenn man professioneller Video-Editor ist, verstehe ich, dass er das voll einleuchtet.
Was ich mag ist, was mir gefällt, er hat sehr spezifische Anforderungen, die er haben will.
Da kann ich mich mit identifizieren.
Ich habe auch immer ganz spezielle Dinge, die ich haben will.
Und ich kaufe dann auch noch was, was das kann.
Ich will die K95 loswerden, da kaufe ich mir jetzt bestimmt keine K55.
Was soll ich mir holen, den QWERTY WRITER 2?
Was ist das denn?
Hat sich schon mal abgedreht an.
Ist klar.
Yes, Schreibmaschine, excellent.
Da kann ich dann endlich meine 20 Romane drauf verfassen, die ich schon im Kopf habe die ganze Zeit
und noch nie zu Papier gebracht habe.
Dafür brauche ich den QWERTY WRITER unbedingt.
So, gucken wir das Video weiter.
Dann noch Pfeife und Monocle, genau.
Ich habe letztens auf Kickstarter einen Monocle gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das war, aber man kann auf Kickstarter Monocle fauten.
Optimus Maximus wäre auch eine Tastatur.
Hört sich an wie Transformer.
In was kannst du dich verwandeln in eine Tastatur?
Was ist das?
Ich bin mit meiner Ducky auch sehr zufrieden.
Ich war vorhin kurz davor, mir eine weitere Ducky One Skyline zu kaufen.
WTF?
Das ist alles ein Screen oder was?
Das ist bestimmt sehr günstig zu haben.
Das ist ja was anderes.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Das geht aber nur bei Software, wo AutoHotkey funktioniert.
Es funktioniert halt nicht bei allem.
Bei vielen Spielen geht AutoHotkey mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Was genau soll die Tastatur alles können?
Eigentlich brauche ich nur eine Tastatur zum Programmieren, also zum Schreiben.
Und eine, mit der man auch gut spielen kann.
Und eine, worauf es mir halt ankommt, dass es eine ordentliche Makrofunktion hat.
Nicht so sehr reine Makrofunktion.
Also ich will nicht nur sagen, eine Taste drückt fünf andere Tasten.
Ich hätte schon gerne ein bisschen Betriebssystem Integration.
So nach dem Motto, wenn ich in dem Fenster bin, dann das.
Und wenn ich in dem Fenster bin, dann vielleicht was anderes.
Razor?
Sind dir die Keys egal?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt, außer MX Speed-Switches,
und ich glaube Brown-Switches ist standardmäßig in der Takiwa und Skyler drin,
noch nichts anderes ausprobiert.
Und die finde ich eigentlich beide ganz gut.
Habe ich auch, brauche ich nicht.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie viele Sterne das auf GitHub hat.
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Ich hätte da echt immer so Mindgames im Hinterkopf.
Wie nennt man das, nicht voreingenommen, sondern immer so aberglaubenmäßig,
immer im Hinterkopf, dass ich irgendwie Input-Lag habe, wenn ich sowas dazwischen habe.
Paranoia, ja, das trifft ganz gut.
Das trifft echt gut.
Ungutes Gefühl Paranoia trifft am besten.
Halt, ich habe übelst Hunger, ich habe noch nichts gegessen.
Aber ich bin noch nicht lange on, das heißt, ich muss jetzt on bleiben.
Und wisst ihr was, Leute, wisst ihr was wir danach machen?
Ich hole mir gleich was zu essen, das dauert zwei Minuten oder drei Minuten.
Da gucken wir ein nice Kochvideo zusammen auf YouTube und ich esse schnell was.
Willst du auch einen Wiener?
Ja, wenn du das jetzt schaffst, irgendwie durch den Twitch-Chat zu pressen,
dann würde ich einen nehmen.
Moment, Moment.
Leute, diese Tastatur hier, das ist der Logitech.
Diese Tastatur hier wollten die uns auf der Arbeit standardmäßig die Arbeitsplätze mit ausrüsten.
Allerdings die Funk-Variante, die Funk-Variante.
Oh, was ist das? Code-Keyboards.
Und das witzige daran ist gewesen, dass quasi von Anfang an die Leute gesagt haben,
also bei den wirklich sicherheitskritischen Arbeitsbereichen,
die quasi Admin-Zugänge haben auf die wichtigsten Systeme und solche Sachen,
sollte man keine Funk-Tastatur verwenden.
Das haben damals die Leute gesagt, lange bevor das rausgekommen ist.
Unsere Leute sind halt clever, sind alle richtig vogue, wie man da so schön sagt.
Die sind einfach aufmerksam gewesen und gesagt, Leute, es ist keine gute Idee,
Arbeitsplätze mit Admin-Zugängen mit Funk-Tastaturen auszustarten.
Und damals hieß es so, wir haben unsere eine Geräte-Strategie und das gibt jetzt die Tastatur.
Eineinhalb Jahre später, tja, jetzt stehen wir da.
Wer weiß, wie viele Admin-Passmörder schon abgegriffen wurden, dank der tollen Bluetooth-Lücke.
Shit happens, ja, Pech gehabt.
Was ich da ganz lustig fand, ist keine Two-Factor-Authentifizierung.
Es kommt drauf an, wofür. Es kommt drauf an, wofür, nicht bei allem.
Ja, bei so Sachen wie, loggt sich auf einem IBM Großrechner ein, da ist mit,
die haben von Two-Factor-Authentifizierung noch nichts gehört.
Die sind aus dem Jahr 1984, also basic-mäßig, unsere sind neu, aber von dem, was da drin ist, ja.
Da ist mit Two-Factor-Authentifizierung nichts.
Du kommst schon von außen auch nicht dran, aber ich mein, man möchte trotzdem nicht,
dass das Passwort mitgeschnitten wird.
Ja, zumindest, ich konnte ruhigengewissens sagen, von mir hat keiner jemals irgendwas abgegriffen,
ich hab, seit wir umgezogen sind und die mir diese komische Logitech-Tastatur hier andrehen wollten,
hab ich mir eine DuckyBorn Skyline gekauft und hab meine Logitech G502 mitgenommen auf die Arbeit
und benutze die Kombination G502 plus DuckyBorn Skyline, alles mit Kabel, so wie sich das gehört.
Wenn eine Admin-Passwörter abgegriffen hat, dann definitiv nicht von mir.
Eigentlich hätte ich jetzt mal hingehen müssen und sagen, Jungs, ich hab schon vorgebeugt,
krieg ich die Tastatur wenigstens ersetzt oder bezahlt von euch.
Aber wisst ihr, was das merkwürdig ist in großen, in so großen Firmen, wie ich arbeite?
Die verstehen bei so was keinen Spaß.
Das sieht bei kleineren Läden anders aus.
Und zwar, wenn ich das denen jetzt noch mal extra unter die Nase gerieben hätte, so nach dem Motto,
ich hab quasi schon vorgesorgt und keine Tastatur genommen, wo man Passwörter abgreifen kann,
dann gibt's ja zwei Varianten.
Entweder würde man sagen, Max, man hat jetzt gesehen, war keine schlechte Idee.
Aber bei uns würde das anders laufen.
Bei uns würde es heißen, was? Du verwendest ein Fremdgerät bei uns.
Das geht aber nicht. Du musst unsere kacke Logitech-Tastatur verwenden.
Das wäre die Logik bei uns gewesen, ey.
Richtig pepega.
Unabhängig davon, ob man da Sachen drüber abgreifen kann, vollkommen wurscht.
Ja, die Logik kennt jeder, der in ein bisschen größeren Laden arbeitet.
Die verstehen keinen Spaß bei sowas, ja?
Das bringt mir alles nichts, wenn ich nicht erkennen kann,
in welcher Anwendung ich bin.
Ein Beispiel mal, weil sich wahrscheinlich viele fragen,
Max, warum willst du erkennen können, in welcher Anwendung du bist?
Ganz einfach. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich hier rüber switche auf meine VM,
will ich, dass der automatisch da rein und raus gehen kann.
Also sprich, wenn ich mein Desktop-Switch-Makro drücke,
ich hab das hier leider nicht drauf, das hab ich auf meinem Main-Account,
wenn ich beispielsweise mein Desktop-Switch-Taste drücke,
dann macht er automatisch, wenn er in der VM drin ist,
macht er automatisch Ctrl-Alt und drückt für mich danach nach 200 Millisekunden
Ctrl-Windows-Taste-File-Taste.
Umgekehrt, wenn ich rüber switche auf die VM,
dann muss er für mich Alt-V drücken, zweimal nach unten
und Enter für Exclusive-Mode, weil das VM immer so scheiße gemacht hat.
Das sind so Sachen, die will ich mit meiner Makrosoftware machen,
deswegen brauch ich eine Makrosoftware, die ein bisschen mit dem Betriebssystem
zusammenhängt, dass man zum Beispiel erkennen kann,
in welcher Anwendung man drin ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir hier irgendwas dafür schon gebastelt haben.
Schauen wir mal, ob ich hier eine Makro-Sache schon drin hab.
Äh, Moment, wie...
Äh, wie ging das hier überhaupt noch mal?
Geht das nicht mit Auto-Hotkey? Nee, das geht nicht mit Auto-Hotkey.
Makro 1.
Alter, diese Software, die macht mich fertig.
Wo konnte man den Kram denn hier nochmal anklicken? Actions.
Genau.
Hier, guckt Leute.
Die haben das eben probiert.
Der geht jetzt, der geht quasi raus hier, drückt das und geht dann rüber.
Und das geht halt nur, wenn man checken kann, äh, also nur mit einer Taste,
wenn man checken kann, in welcher Anwendung man drin ist und sowas.
Was hier jetzt nicht geht.
Sowas will ich halt mit der Makro-Software machen.
Ich will die, also ein Ziel, was ich hab, ist halt, dass die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Linux und Windows hier nebeneinander so problemlos wie möglich funktioniert.
Mit der Logitech-Software funktioniert das richtig gut, ja.
Geht das nicht mit Auto-Hotkey? Nee, mit Auto-Hotkey geht das nicht.
Weil Auto-Hotkey kann zum Beispiel keine Tastatureingaben in eine VM senden.
Geht nicht.
Weil VM ja quasi keine Windows-Tastatureingaben entgegennimmt,
sondern irgendeinen Low-Level-Keyboard, USB-Treiber, Hook, was auch immer hat
und die sich überhaupt nicht dafür interessieren, was Windows für Tastatureingaben schickt.
Kauf doch einfach eine Logitech-Tastatur.
Das würde ich machen, ich hab noch keine Logitech-Tastatur gefunden, die mir gefällt.
Es gibt Macros, Layers und RGB-Support, natürlich.
Aber es gibt auch spezielle Sachen, wie Space Cadet Shift,
welches deine Shift-Keys als Parenthese benutzt, wenn du sie einfach tappst.
Unicode-Support, welches genau was du erwartest.
Und Tapdance, welches verschiedene Funktionen aus dem gleichen Key nennt,
depending upon how many times you tap it.
Deutsches.
CPU, was ist denn da drauf?
Ne, Cheetoaner, ich will das einfach benutzen.
Ich will jetzt nicht das Rad neu erfinden, plus, dass ich Desktop switchen kann.
Ist da ein ESP drinne? Was ist denn da drinne?
Ah, das weiß ich.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Tastatur, die das Gegenteil von Control-Z macht?
Ja, entweder Steuerung Y oder Shift-Control-Z. Kommt ein bisschen auf die Software an.
Hast du mit AutoHotkey mal geschaut, ob das nicht geht?
Ja, hab ich.
Das war das erste, was ich ausprobiert habe.
Ja gut, es hat logischerweise keinerlei Betriebssystems-Schnittstelle,
weil es ist ja eine extra Hardware, ohne Software auf dem Host-Rechner drauf.
Du wirst lachen auf meinem Main-Windows-Profil, was ich verwende, wenn ich nicht streame.
Dann mache ich das Switchen sogar mit der Logitech-Maus.
Weil die Logitech-Microsoft eigentlich die beste ist.
Jeder macht es jetzt auch so ein bisschen lustig, aber wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich nicht schwierig,
wenn man ein bisschen was in der Richtung schon gemacht hat.
Ich dachte, er zeigt ein bisschen mehr, was man mit dem Gerät macht.
Ich kann so ein Ding nicht dazwischen stecken.
Ich habe bei jedem Game Komplexe, das ich Input-Lag habe.
Geht nicht.
Ah, das ist ein Arduino, guck mal.
Oder zumindest was Arduino-ähnliches.
Das sind die Arduino-Dinger.
Also ich vermute mal ganz stark, dass das irgendwas, zumindest Arduino-ähnliches sein wird, was da drauf ist.
Einfach zwei Tastaturen, eine zum Spiel einzuprogrammieren.
Du wirst lachen, das habe ich mir schon tatsächlich überlegt.
Aber ich will keine zwei Tastaturen hier rumstehen haben.
Ich habe ja auch eine Tastatur für zwei Rechner hier.
Wozu soll ich für jeden Rechner eine Tastatur hinstellen?
Ich kann einfach Maus-Tastatur scheren.
Und dann kann ich einfach eine Tastatur scheren.
Doch, wenn die Tasten nicht Standard groß sind, glaube ich nicht, dass ich damit klarkomme.
Mich nerven ja schon die etwas zu rutschigen Tasten auf der K95.
Also wenn das alles, was nicht Standard ist, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich gucke es mir mal an.
Aber Auto-Hotkey kann ich verwenden?
Ich kann kein Auto-Hotkey verwenden.
Also erstens, weil mit Auto-Hotkey nicht funktioniert, was ich machen will.
Was hier das Switchen angeht und sowas.
Das größte Problem ist aber, dass in vielen Spielen Auto-Hotkey entweder die Spiele nicht starten oder als Cheat erkannt werden.
Wobei hauptsächlich die Spiele nicht starten, wenn man Auto-Hotkey anhat.
Das ist doof.
Ah, ja.
So ein Rumgefricke.
Warum kann Auto-Hotkey ein tausendmal mehr Zeug tun?
Das andere kann man in C selbst programmieren.
Da kann man doch definitiv genauso viel machen.
Also rein Tastatur-mäßig.
Interaktion mit Betriebssystem natürlich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, das bringt mir ja nichts.
Weil das wofür ich es brauche, wenn Auto-Hotkey nicht geht und Auto-Hotkey in Spielen oftmals Probleme macht.
Ich weiß, ich komme mir manchmal mit sowas vor, als bin ich der Einzige auf der Welt, der so Probleme hat.
Ah, Kacknup.
Egal, ich muss noch nicht weiter angucken.
Lohnt es, glaube ich, nicht, dass ich damit das machen kann, was ich machen will.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Aber was ich jetzt mal gucken wollte, ist eigentlich, was sagt denn, bevor wir uns die ganzen anderen Tastaturen angucken,
was sagt denn eigentlich die Pizzi Games Hardware dazu, was Tastaturen beste sind?
Hol dir jetzt dein Essen.
Sehr gute Idee.
Könnt ihr schon mal überlegen, was wir für ein Kochvideo gucken.
Was gucken wir denn?
Cooking.
Ich gucke keinen Gordon Ramsay, das sage ich aber klar.
Cooking Korean, Korean food.
Wir gucken uns Koreanisch an.
How to make Korean Bulgogi.
Bibimbap.
Ne, wir gucken Dings hier.
Da gibt es auch diesen Steak Test Channel, die immer so Steaks ausprobieren.
Was Klaus grillt?
Was ist Klaus grillt?
Ich habe überhaupt nichts.
Willkommen.
Grillt er auch wirklich?
Ne, das ist zu wenig Kochen.
Das ist zu wenig Kochen.
So, ich will irgendwas Koreanisches gucken.
Korean Bulgogi.
Korean Crab.
What the fuck?
Moment.
Sieht das nur so aus?
Oder ist das sehr Thumbnail vorteilhaft programmiert?
Islamisch programmiert, Alter, aufgenommen.
Ich glaube, das ist sehr vorteilhaft für ein Thumbnail, aufgenommen.
Das sieht gut aus.
Koreanische Oma kocht, was soll da schiefgehen?
Koreanische Oma kocht, da kann nichts schiefgehen.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Best Ramen Soup.
Best Ramen Recipe.
Den gucken wir uns jetzt alle an.
Ich meine, wir können uns jetzt schon sagen, er wird alles machen außer Raben kochen.
Leute, jetzt mal Warnung bei den Videos, das wird definitiv eklig gleich.
Das sieht nur am Anfang so aus.
Der will euch zubaten.
Ja, das wird definitiv eklig.
Die Videos von dem fangen immer so an und dann gehen sie komplett in die falsche Richtung.
Oder was heißt die falsche?
In die andere Richtung.
Man denkt jetzt so nach dem Motto, hey, das ist doch ein normales Kochvideo.
Ist es nicht?
Was ist ab?
Aber wahrscheinlich kennen die meisten.
Der hat 14 Millionen Subscriber.
Wo geht es denn los?
Okay, ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Das ist übelst abgedreht, die Videos von dem Kerl.
Okay, wir werden echt krass zubatet, aber lange kann das immer dauern.
Es geht schon los.
Ich sag doch, die Videos gehen auf einmal in eine sehr merkwürdige Richtung.
Jetzt fehlt bloß das Ei.
Das Ei kommt garantiert auch wieder.
Viele Nudeln, viele.
Da kommt noch irgendwas, das kann doch nicht alles sein.
Also das Ei muss mal mindestens da einmal.
Oder es springt jetzt rein oder irgendwie sowas.
Da springt er jetzt rein, irgendwas muss da jetzt noch kommen.
Es wird immer mehr Nudeln.
Ist ja gut.
Bis jetzt ist noch wirklich nichts passiert, das kann eigentlich überhaupt nicht sein.
Der muss sich jetzt da drin rumrollen oder sowas noch.
Okay, er hat es echt übertrieben wieder.
Der Kerl hat so einen Knall.
Aber das Video ist für ihn echt harmlos.
Normalerweise ist das deutlich ekliger.
Okay, Leute, ich hole mir jetzt was zu essen.
Mal gucken, was ein Kochvideo an.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay, Leute, ich hole mir jetzt was zu essen.
Okay, Leute, heute dieses Touchfilm.
So, jetzt essen wir erstmal schnell was, dabei gucken wir uns an, von kurz zu Rahmen, Basics mit Babish.
So, dann zeichne ich so was, Babish.
Ich hab von ihr noch nie was gesehen.
Squarespace ist Big Brain Sellout, machen ganz viele jetzt.
So, aber aber.
Ich hab Aya.
Ich hab mir ja mal so welche bestellt aus Japan.
Ich hatte mir die einzigen Michelin Sternen, die einzigen Michelin Sternen Instant Ramen Suppe aus Japan bestellt, aber viel zu teuer.
Durch hin und her schicken und alles. Wobei man sagen muss, dass die Suppe hat kein Stern, sondern der Koch in dem Restaurant hat halt einen Stern, nicht die Instant Suppe.
Kennst du Alex den French Guy? Nee, French.
Ich überleg grad, wie das hieß, was ich bestellt hatte.
Warte mal, warte mal. Irgendwie Zuba, Ramen, Zuta, Zuta, Soba, Soba, Soba, Soba.
Instant Zuta. Ja, das da. Genau, da hatte ich mir so einen Pack bestellt.
Das Problem ist halt, dass das mit Versand und Import viel zu teuer ist.
Ich mein, es ist die beste Instant Nudelsuppe, die ich je gegessen hab, aber es ist eine Instant Nudelsuppe, ja.
Schau dir mal Shinrai, was, Raimund an. Woll jetzt eigentlich was essen.
Gibt's Amazon? Oder wo, wo kauft man die? Amazon.
Koreanische Rahmensuppe scharf, 20.
Könnte man sich mal geben, ja. Find ich gut.
Das wird jetzt gar nix. Aber wir gucken dem Typ zu, wie er Suppe macht.
Und Solaris. Ah ne, nicht Solaris. Solaris, aber fast. Solar von Astora.
Alter Farben halt, ja.
Triggert mich schon wieder. Könnte ich gescheite Einheiten verwenden.
Nee, ich würde eher sagen England.
Erst mal schön, ja.
Macht der da platt? Ich hab exakt keine Ahnung, was er macht. Ich dachte er wollte Suppe machen. Was macht der da eigentlich?
Ich bin zu sehr mit meinem Essen beschäftigt, aber ich dachte er wollte Suppe machen. Ah, Nudeln.
Chat. Chat ist hier wieder voll aufmerksam dabei. Oh, nice. Ein nice Nudel.
Teig. Hast du deine neue Tastatur gefunden? Nee, wir müssen noch ein paar Sachen durchgucken.
Das kann man bestimmt auch so essen. Ah, das ist hier Schweinebauch oder was ist das?
Die machen immer Schweinebauch rein. Das ist Schweinebauch okay.
Wenn ihr ein geiles Video sehen wollt, guckt ihr das Lasagne Video an. Ach, ich brauche noch ein bisschen bis ich fertig geputtert habe.
Das Ei sieht gut aus. Also das würde ich mir jetzt, ich würde mir das Instant reinhauen. Wollen wir mal kurz das Mikro ein bisschen hoch machen.
Das sieht gut aus. Ah, yes, Squarespace. Okay, gucken wir uns die Lasagne noch an.
Was? Lasagne. Lasagna. Welches davon? Das da?
Das da? Das obere? Lasagne von Garfield? Welches ist das richtige? Ja, das oberste.
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die mixed Feelings about Lasagne haben? Ich kenne keinen, der nicht zumindest Lasagne essen kann.
Das dauer ich nicht Patrick, das gibt jeder Kalle Lasagne essen. Ohje, die Veganer, die sind eh schon stinkig auf Twitter, auf mich.
Kiosk, schieß los. Ah, excellent Wine, excellent. Zwar Rotwein bei mir im Bild, aber ich habe nichts anderes jetzt.
Gut eingebrannt, kein Problem. Du kannst einfach mal in der Mutter gehen zum sauber machen.
Also Leute, das könnte man auch so essen, oder? Paar Nudeln dabei, um gut zu essen.
Oh, ich will jetzt, ohne scheiß Leute, scheiß auf mein Brot, ich hätte jetzt gerne mal so eine ordentliche Portion Nudeln mit irgendwie Bolognese Soße und irgendwie so einem halben Liter Parmesan Käse drauf.
Nico, zuerst Dankeschön. Aunsis, ja. Aunsis, Alter.
Ich bin hier die Nettenhöhe von Düsseldorf, nee. Wobei nach Köln ist es eine Stunde, da ist Düsseldorf auch nicht so weit.
Nee, eine neue Corsair hole ich mir nicht, Kiosk. Nee, die will ich ja gerade loswerden.
Malken 120, ich muss mir gleich mal angucken, wir haben jetzt viele empfohlen, aber das ist Razor oder so.
Es ist ein Essen, ein Essen.
Ordentlich, ordentlich Parmesan drauf, so muss das sein.
Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr irgendwie Nudeln Bolognese oder so esst, dass die Hälfte, wenn ich sogar drei Viertel gefühlt von dem was ihr gegessen habt am Ende aus Parmesan Käse bestanden haben, ich schmeiß da immer gefühlt einen halben Liter oder so drauf.
Ich baue immer extra ein neues Päckchen auf, wenn ich Bolognese, Soße, Futter und ich sag dann, okay, probierst du erst mal so, probierst du erst mal so, denk ich so, schmeckt ja auch so, gar nicht so schlecht, gar nicht so schlecht und irgendwann so nach ein paar Mal Essen, ein paar Mal, paar Portionen gefuttert, sag ich dann so, denk ich mir immer, ey machst du ein bisschen Parmesan Käse, machst ein bisschen, ich reib den Parmesan Käse nicht.
Ne, selbst, das ist fertig aus der Tüte.
So, und dann mach ich ein bisschen Parmesan drauf, aber sobald ich Parmesan Käse draufgeschmissen hab, muss ich ja quasi nach jedem Mal, nach jedem Löffel, nach jeder Gabel muss ich einen neuen Parmesan Käse draufschreiben, draufschmeißen.
Und 45 Minuten später, es ist Zeit, um reinzulegen.
Und nach den langen 30 Minuten in unserem Leben, ist es Zeit, um reinzulegen. Und wie ihr vermutlich wisst, hat es einen verdammten Käse-Stretch.
Ah, yes, exzellent.
Ich brauch noch mehr zu essen, Leute, das war zu wenig.
So ein Brötchen, das ist nix.
Ich brauch mehr, ich hätte mir keine Kochvideos angucken sollen, ich brauch mehr Essen, Leute, zu wenig.
Krieg ich jetzt noch mehr zu essen, ja.
Egal, das muss ich jetzt aushalten.
Was, AliExpress, was geht mit denen ab? Kleiner, süßer Skorpion.
Weil Skorpione ja auch bekannt dafür sind, dass die so klein und süß sind, ne?
Ja, der DT-Kahn, ganz bestimmt.
Okay, da speichern wir noch mal.
Also, Tastatur, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Was sagt denn die PC Games Hardware zu Tastaturen?
Die empfiehlt mir, die Tastatur nicht loswerden will. Ja, super, toll.
Ne, ist was anderes.
Ich mein, die sehen sich einfach nur so ähnlich.
Die sehen sich einfach nur so ähnlich, die ganze RGB-Crap da.
Okay, was haben wir hier zu...
Festzieger, Coolmaster MK850, Ducky Shine, warum hat die so ne Kackwertung auf...
Nachteile keine, das glaub ich nicht, alles hat irgendwie Nachteile.
Was für ne Tastatur willst du haben? Ja, was zum Schreiben, also zum Programmieren und was zum Spielen.
Und vor allem ne ordentliche Makro-Software.
Warum möchtest du die Corsana loswerden? Weil, ich fass dir das jetzt noch mal kurz zusammen.
Ich hab's nämlich auf Twitter schon mal geschrieben.
Unter anderem, ich hab's vorhin auch ein bisschen ausführlicher erklärt.
Unter anderem, weil das Ding doppelte Tastenanschläge hat, weil es ein komisches Layout hat,
weil ich immer mit dem Finger zwischen Steuerung und Funktionstaste rutsche,
dass die Tastenoberfläche mir zu rutschig ist, dass die Tasten wackeln,
dass das Ding bei mir massig Staub und Dreck einfängt und,
dass die Software im Hintergrund permanent zibula ist und frisst.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich ne Ducky One Skyline, mit der bin ich auch zufrieden.
Allerdings hat die keine ordentliche Makro-Software, sonst würd ich mir noch eine kaufen.
Du kennst keins von diesen Problemen? Ja, vielleicht hast du die Problemen auch nicht.
Das ist ja was Individuelles, ja.
Außer mit doppelten Tastenanschlägen.
Michael, das hab ich hier irgendwo auch schon drinne stehen, das Ding.
Kost?
Geht doch eigentlich.
So, warte mal. Was sagen die denn dazu?
Wo ist eigentlich meine gelandet?
Hier.
KVM und RGB-Platinum-Achterplatz.
Äh.
Alter, die Musik. Was ist da los?
Ah, das ist auch Carina of Time.
Oder? Ja, ich glaub schon.
Was stand hier unten, glaub ich, gerade?
Das Vorschau bildet das Stream-Ankündigung.
Ah, das Kochvideo!
Ja, ich hab mir gedacht, wenn ich jetzt schon euch was vorfutter,
dann kann ich euch ein Kochvideo anmachen.
Jetzt, das Problem ist, ich hab jetzt noch mehr Hunger.
Ich will eine mechanische Tastatur haben.
Okay, also was ist an der Tastatur so toll? Cool Master.
Was sagen sie? Also, man muss ja sagen, vielleicht soll ich das mal ausmachen.
Sieht ein bisschen besser aus.
Cherry MX Red RGB.
Was hat meine?
Cherry MX Speed RGB.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Red und Speed?
Was sagst du, zur G910 hab ich noch nicht angeguckt.
Makrospeicher, USB, okay, blablabla.
Lautstärke? Welche davon ist lauter?
Rocket, ich will mir eigentlich keine Rocket kaufen.
Ah, hier.
Also, was? Nur mal so, ihr kennt euch da wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich haben ihr ein paar Pros.
Ich hab ja so eine auf der Arbeit.
Was ist denn da standardmäßig drin? Brown, oder? Brown Switches.
Switches.
Alter, die Musik, was ist jetzt los?
Blue? Red? Ich muss mal kurz gucken bei Amazon, was ich mir gekauft hab.
So, jetzt muss ich mich noch einloggen.
Passwort ist incorrect.
Passwort ist incorrect. Warum?
Warum ist das Passwort incorrect?
Nee, geht doch.
Mist, die hab ich nicht über Amazon gekauft, fuck.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was ich für Switches hab.
Hm.
Blue Switches? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich für Switches hab.
Du kannst eine Tastenkappe von deiner Tastatur abnehmen.
Das bringt mir nichts, die hab ich auf der Arbeit.
Hier hab ich eine K95 Platinum, die will ich ja loswerden.
Welche, also, ich hab hier die K95 hier.
So, und das sind ja angeblich MX Speed.
So, sind MX Speed, sind das Clicky-Tasten, taktile Tasten, lineare Tasten?
Also, man, so einen richtigen, richtigen Klick hört man nicht.
Man hört, man hört an der Stelle, wenn man unten ankommt halt.
Ja, ich glaube, ich hab, ich glaube auch, dass ich Brown Switches hab.
Linear sind die, okay.
Was ist so euer Favorit? Davon?
Wichtig, ich muss, ich muss Strafe spammen.
Nee, ich mach's hin.
Also, Brown ist doch eher taktil.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß nur, dass sie deutlich mehr klicken als die Tastatur, die ich hier daheim hab.
Brown mit Rings, genau das hab ich auch, exakt.
Das hab ich auch bei meiner Ducky One.
Ich hab Brown, ich hab, ich, genau, ich hab Brown Switches und diese Silikonringe drunter.
Zum Zocken, Rot und Kompromiss ist Brown.
Also, wäre ein Brown, Brown Switch für mich ganz gut, oder?
Weil ich ja, ich mein, ich will relativ viel tippen, schreiben, aber auch spielen.
Ein paar Switches anhören, oh, da gibt's denn ein Zuhörvideo.
Typing Sounds.
Krass, was es alles gibt für Videos.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, du spielst Shooter hauptsächlich, ja, aber spiel alles mögliche.
Aber wenn es auf competitive Aspekt ankommt, dann Shooter.
Wobei ich sagen muss, die linearen Tasten hier daheim, die finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Wenn MX Speed linear sind.
Die haben keinen, die haben keinen Klick.
Die machen null Klick, wenn ich da nicht, wenn ich da nicht anhaue.
Also, wenn ich die einfach nur runterdrücke, dann hör ich keinen Klick.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, muss ich sagen.
Weil ich bin ja hier auch manchmal früh auf, mach spät auf.
Ich will gar nicht so sehr auf die Tasten hier hauen.
Also, auf der Armheit muss ich sagen, sind die Brown-Switches von der Ducky One Skyline.
Ich hab ganz erträglich, aber das ist ja auch in einem Großraumbüro.
Da ist das jetzt manchmal ein bisschen nervig für die Leute.
Aber bisher hat sich noch keiner groß beschwert.
Habt ihr eine Tastatur mit Kabel oder Funk?
Also ich bin ja einer, der mag alles mit Kabel haben.
Maus-Kabel, Tastatur-Kabel.
Cool Master MK 850.
170 Euro, ok.
Das kostet genau, kostet genau.
Oh nee, die gefällt mir nicht.
Die gefällt mir nicht.
Die hat ja genau das gleiche Problem, wie die aktuelle Tastatur, die ich hab.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Nein, garantiert nicht.
Ist dir das Layout egal?
Also es sollte schon ein deutsches Tastatur-Layout haben.
Und auch die ganzen Sondertasten sollten da sein, wo sie sind.
Also hier Raute und Backslash und so.
Corsair.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich eine Corsair holen will.
TT Esports Challenger Edge Pro.
Was ist das für ein Name?
Geh mal fort.
Logitech.
Ich würde mir eine Ducky One Sky anholen, ohne Scheiß.
Bei der weiß ich, dass sie was taugt.
Da hab ich schon jetzt über ein Jahr auch Erfahrung mit gesammelt.
Das einzige, warum ich es mir halt nicht hole, ist, weil es keine gescheite Microsoft-Ware hat.
Machen wir es doch mal umgedreht.
Welche Hersteller haben gescheite Microsoft-Ware?
Logitech weiß ich.
Dieses IQ ist vorhanden, so wirklich geil ist es nicht.
Razer hat irgendwie Synapse-Zeug, das soll ganz gut sein.
Rocket.
Was?
Glorious GMMK.
Echt, findest du die Corsair-Makros gut?
Ich find diese Software hier eine übelste Zumutung eigentlich.
Guck dir das mal an.
Für das Software ist eigentlich total die Zumutung.
Brauchst du die Makros nur für deine Emotes?
Nein, für meine Emotes brauch ich das nicht.
Ich brauch die Makros zum Beispiel zum Switchen von Desktops und VM, dass das richtig funktioniert.
Also es ist aber einfacher, noch einfacher funktioniert.
Glorious GMMK, Full-Size.
Kokona-Build.
Huge.
Das ist die G513.
Warum ist die Benahmung bei Logitech eigentlich so wir?
Logitech hat gefühlt jede Nummer mittlerweile besetzt.
Zu billig.
SteelSeries.
Ja, ich kenne die SteelSeries-Software nicht.
Wenn du sagst, die ist gut, kann man sich das mal angucken.
Die haben dich wirklich escape.
Das ist jetzt nicht dir denn ernst, oder?
Die Escape-Taste.
Die Glorious PC Gamer Master Race Tastatur.
Was war Case King?
Aber das hat keine gescheite Makrosoftware, oder?
Was ist denn zu billig für ein Kriterium?
Big Brain Kriterium.
Da fehlen die Tasten.
Also so ist das keine Tastatur.
What?
Die sind da keine Tasten dabei, oder was?
Ah, man kann sich das hier nach Switches kaufen.
Okay.
Der Case King.
Das ist nicht der Laden, wo der Auer für arbeitet.
Barebone, Barebone.
Der Tastatur-Konfigurator.
Zwo, der erste, naja, gut, das werden sie.
Ja, und wo kann man jetzt da die Tasten auswählen?
Ich check's irgendwie nicht, das ist mir zu Big Brain.
Ah, hier, Switch-Typ.
Boah.
Was ich was ich da nehmen soll?
Clear Switches, Green Switches, Blue Switches.
Das wird schon wieder zu kompliziert einfach.
Tastatur.
Black Box Switches, Brown Switches.
Hier gibt es da Brown Switches und da Brown Switches.
Ich würde mir sofort eine Ducky kaufen.
Aber wegen der Macrosoftware kann ich mir keine kaufen.
Das check ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu Big Brain, das hier zusammenzuklicken.
Die Rabennudeln wegmachen, ich weiß nicht, was soll ich mehr kaufen?
Eigentlich am liebsten würde ich mal wieder so eine kaufen.
Da weiß ich, dass er was taugt, das Ding ist richtig massiv und ist eigentlich gut.
Aber die Macrosoftware suckt halt.
Wartet mal, wie ist dieses Ding?
USB, H, Dings hier.
Gibt es da vielleicht einen Windows-Client, der checken kann, welche Anwendung man drin ist?
Kann das Ding nicht, ne?
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe immer Input-Lack, wenn ich da was dazwischen stöpsel, das kann ich nicht machen.
Eigene Macrosoftware bauen, das ist nicht so einfach, wie es aussieht.
Leute, wenn noch einer Auto-Hotkey schreibt.
GKL-Doubleshotters, es gibt so viel, das überfordert mich voll.
Das überfordert mich voll.
Nee, die gefällt mir nicht, weil abgerundete Tasten hier unten, das mag ich gar nicht.
Was hast du für eine Maus, dann kannst du alles mit Logitech-Maus.
Ich mache ja auch viel mit der Logitech-Software, aber ich kann ja schlecht Tasten auf der Tastatur mit was belegen,
die nicht von Logitech ist mit der Logitech-Software.
Es gibt so 30 Milliarden verschiedene Dinge.
Eine Klapperkiste, die gefällt mir auch nicht.
Die sieht genauso, das ist genau der gleiche Typ-Tastatur, die ich eigentlich loswerden will.
Logitech finde ich irgendwie nichts, das mir gefällt von der Tastatur her.
Eigentlich will ich eine Ducky One Skyline haben, mit ordentlicher Makro-Software.
Guckt euch mal diese Anleitung an, die eingebaute Makro-Funktion ist ein bisschen doof.
Da musst du irgendwelche Jumper auf der Rückseite machen und so.
Hast du hier schon mal Cherry-Tastatur? Nee, aber die haben auch keine gescheite Makro-Software und Cherry-Switches haben sie alle.
Wer braucht schon Makros in der Tastatur?
Ist da vielleicht irgendwas zu, was einer schon gebastelt hat?
Was? Ducky API?
Key-Lighting, ich will ordentliche Makros.
Das hab ich mir gerade angeguckt, das Ding.
Ich war zu blöd, das zu konfigurieren.
Ich war zu doof, das Ganze zu konfigurieren.
Gucken wir mal bei Amazon.
Warum war das so schlechte Bewertung?
Wie findest du die Logitech Pro X?
Hä? Das ist ein Headset.
Ist das eine Tastatur? Moment, das ist auch eine Tastatur?
Logitech Benamung, beste.
Gibt's die auch mit NumBlock?
Gibt's die mit NumBlock?
NumBlock?
Ich will aber nur NumBlock.
Kann doch nicht so schwierig sein.
Ich will eine NumBlock, eine ordentliche Makro-Software
und eine Tastatur, die einfach Tastatur ist und funktioniert.
Wozu brauchst du eine NumBlock? Weil ich gerne eine NumBlock verwende.
Ich fahr's, denn irgendwie ist das viel schwieriger als gedacht hab.
Weil er ein Boomer ist, kann er noch weitergucken als 15 cm zum Smartphone-Bildschirm.
Deswegen brauch ich auch Big Brain-Funktionen in meiner Tastatur, die Zoomer nicht brauchen.
Zum Beispiel ordentliche Makro-Software.
Lokalen Flohmarkt?
Okay, okay, Surf Jelly...
Da, meinste. So, ich guck mir das jetzt an.
So, Ascent. Wir ascenden erstmal.
Compact. Das ist die Variante... Nee, nee, nee, das mag ich nicht.
Was? The Keyboard.
Da gibt's da ein Bild von der Makro-Software.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal...
nicht das, was ich brauch.
Ich brauch eine Makro-Software, die auch erkennt, was für eine Anwendung gerade aktiv ist. So wie Logitech das mit den Profilen macht.
Ich seh's schon kommen. Das wird wahrscheinlich... Wahrscheinlich komm ich mit in die Logitech-Tastatur.
Auch wenn ich mit den Logitech-Tastaturen irgendwie nicht so warm werde.
Puh.
Das ist echt kompliziert, so eine Kacktastatur zu kaufen.
Sofort Software.
Das G502 Carbon mit NumBlock. Also die Logitech Produktbezeichnung.
Ok, das sieht wenigstens mal nach einer Tastatur aus.
Einfach eine stinknormale Tastatur.
Natürlich mit RGB.
Die Tasten sind ordentlich geformt.
Das Ding hat NumBlock.
Das macht jetzt erstmal einen ganz passablen Eindruck.
Und die ist nicht so teuer.
Aber zu billig.
Ich muss ja das Gefühl haben, was Gutes zu kaufen. Also ohne 150 Euro geht da nichts.
Aber die macht echt einen guten Eindruck.
Die sieht einfach aus wie eine Tastatur.
Was für Switches sind da drinnen?
Kann man das auswählen?
Die Logitech Bezeichnungen sind mir zu big brain.
Ah, schön teuer. Das ist gut.
Ih, flache Tasten. Oh nee.
Keine flachen Tasten.
Kein Fall.
Ich weiß, ich bin da sehr wählerisch was das angeht, aber ich finde nichts.
Ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, was ich für Switches haben will ehrlich gesagt.
Eigentlich finde ich diese MX-Speed-Switches hier ganz gut.
Weil die sind nicht so laut.
Minus 380, bock.
Blue kann man auswählen.
Ah, das ist dann quasi so ein bisschen wie die Speed-Switches.
Leute, vielleicht mache ich es auch einfach viel zu kompliziert.
Ich bin verwirrt, Logitech.
Was ist der Unterschied hiervon? Die hat auch nur einen Block.
Das ist eine andere, sehe ich.
Logitech-Benahmungen.
Aber hier kann man die Switche nicht auswählen bei Amazon.
Handballen-Auflage bin ich mir nur unschlüssig.
Da will ich mir wahrscheinlich was Eigenes, was du jetzt legst kaufen.
Ja, dann vielleicht doch eine G500 Rad-Cine.
Den hier waren die leisen, oder?
Also 139 Euro und die Logitech-Software ist auch gut.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Das macht doch eigentlich einen ganz passablen Eindruck, das Ding.
Bei der habe ich gesagt, die ist zu günstig.
Ja, das war ein Witz.
Lieferung bis Montag.
Ah, bis morgen geht nicht mehr.
Ich habe eine Big-Brain-Idee. Massive-Brain.
Ich suche einfach eine andere Tastatur, die morgen lieferbar ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es zu spät.
Wahrscheinlich ist es 21.20 Uhr, das funktioniert eh nicht mehr.
Da ist nichts bis morgen lieferbar.
Ja, dann doch Montag.
Ist aber vom Frame her wie deine.
Das ist ja nicht... Ach so.
Ah, ich sehe es.
Aber die doch auch.
So, überhaupt kein Unterschied, oder?
In mein lokales Geschäft. Glaubst du nicht ernsthaft, dass ich in irgendeinen Saturn gehe und da was kaufe?
Also erstens müsste ich da unter Menschen gehen. Das ist ja schon mal nicht auszudenken.
Und zweitens will ich dem Saturn kein Geld geben.
Was der hauptsächliche Grund ist.
Warum tauchen Nachricht von SirCybot nicht im Stream auf?
Äh, gute Frage.
Bot im Namen. Oh, stimmt.
Okay, dann ist das ein ziemlicher Fail von Steamlabs.
Also ich muss euch jetzt ehrlich sagen, ich meine, ich checke null die Logitech Benamung.
Ich muss sagen, das Ding hier macht doch eigentlich...
Das Teil macht doch eigentlich einen ganz passablen Eindruck.
Die haben eine ordentliche Makrosoftware.
Preis ist okay.
Die Tasten sind nicht gebogen.
Nach außen gewölbt, so rum.
Das hat einen Lumblock.
Nee, nee, ich hole deutsche Tastatur layout.
Alle Logitech Tasten unter dem Link, okay. Gucken wir mal.
Media Keys brauche ich nicht.
Media Keys ist wirklich so ein Ding, habe ich überhaupt keine Verwendung für.
Zumal Media Keys ja auch unter Windows kaputt sind, ne.
Guck mal, wenn ich sagen möchte hier, Pause.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es, okay.
Es geht nämlich manchmal nicht.
Aber sag doch mal ehrlich, die Logitech Benamung ist doch nicht logisch, oder?
Oder vielleicht logisch, weil man das irgendwie studiert hat.
Beleuchtung. Brauche ich nicht.
Tastaturtyp.
Wired.
Serie ist mir auch egal. Tastaturtyp.
Was ist denn Mech, Mech Dome?
Hä?
Moment, ist, die ist doch auch wired.
Warum taucht die jetzt hier nicht auf?
Ich habe gesagt, mechanisch und mit Kabel.
Warum taucht die hier jetzt nicht auf?
Die ist mechanisch und mit Kabel.
Hm.
Wired.
Ach, wartet mal vorher mal Wireless.
Oder?
Aber wobei ich doch Wired ausgewählt habe.
Die steht da wieder nicht drinnen.
Hä? Warum taucht die da nicht auf drinnen?
Das gibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn. Wired? Mechanisch? Taucht das da durch nicht auf?
Warum?
Egal, ist ja auch egal.
Also ich finde das Ding macht einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Oh, huge Video.
Ja, natürlich was sonst.
Moment, was? Was? Was fehlt da? Hab ich das jetzt nicht gesehen?
Das rechte Shift.
Ah, Moment.
Was ist das?
Was ist das für ein Crap? Das sehe ich ja jetzt erst.
Nee, Moment. Das ist Ami-Layout. Das ist Ami-Layout.
Kokona-Layout. Ich muss mir das mal auf Deutsch angucken.
Was?
Hallo.
Ich kann mir das mal auf Deutsch einfach zeigen.
Nee. Mach mal nicht. Macht der Amazon zu? Ah, hier.
Das ist okay.
Das deutsche System ist sich degeneriert. Alle Programmiersprachen wurden aber auf englischen Tastaturen erfunden.
Deswegen ist das englische Layout zum Programmieren eigentlich besser. Einziges Problem ist, wenn man ans deutsche Layout gewöhnt ist.
Ich finde das lohnt sich nicht, das neu zu lernen, ganz ehrlich. Man kann seine Zeit auch besser investieren.
Also das Ding hier macht doch einen echt passablen Eindruck. Ich meine, es hat eine gute Microsoft-Ware, es hat einen Num-Block, es hat so das Tastature-Layout, was man haben will, normalerweise.
Ich glaube, das Ding probiere ich mal aus. Ich glaube, das Ding probiere ich mal aus.
Ich finde es auch gut, da ist auch eine Handballen-Ablage dabei, die nicht so ein komisches Plastikgummi-Ding ist wie von der Corsair.
Ich glaube, das Ding bestelle ich mir mal.
So, gibt es jetzt irgendwas, was ich vergessen habe oder übersehen habe, was komplett gegen diese Tastatur spricht?
Ich glaube nicht, aber kann er sein.
Ach, welche Switches. Ja, stimmt. Ja, die hier. Die, die nicht so einen Krach machen.
Muss man wissen, ob man die mag. Ja, das kann man wahrscheinlich nur durch Ausprobieren rauskriegen.
Alter, dieses Marketing-Geschwätze immer. Hochwertiges Top-Case mit 552 Legierungen aus Flugzeug-Aluminium.
Ist Flugzeug-Aluminium irgendwie kein Aluminium mehr oder was?
Aufpassen, die gibt es auch künstiger. Ja, ich sehe es gerade. Muss ich mal gucken.
Du hast ja 50 Euro weniger. Kosse. Hab ich ja nie gehört.
Auch bei Amazon. Hä? Hä? Ah, Moment. Taktil, denn ja. Nee, da sind wir wieder beim gleichen.
Neu und Gebraucht ab. Monte Arenas. Warum kostet das nur die Hälfte wie bei Amazon?
Ah, Gebraucht. Gebraucht. Gebraucht. Geh mal fort. Nee, das gibt es nicht.
Otto. Deutsche Otto-Lahn. Dachte, du wolltest Taktil. Ich weiß nicht so genau, was ich wollte.
Ich wollte quasi die, die keinen Krach machen und so ein bisschen wie die MX-Speed-Switches sind.
Mediamarkt. Ne, geh ich nicht hin. Ist die Handballen-Ablage abnehmbar?
Eine exzellente Big-Brain-Frage. Wahrscheinlich. Sieht so aus, als wäre die einfach nur angeklippt.
Also sprich, entweder mit irgendwie einem Klettverschluss oder so. Ah, sind magnetisch.
Okay. Taktil ist ohne Krach mit Feedback und Linear ist ohne Krach.
Vielleicht will ich dann tatsächlich Taktil haben.
Prime. Gebraucht. Nein, geh weg. Die gibt es nicht. Ah, yes. Zu begehrt, die Tastatur.
Okay. Dann gucken wir mal ein paar Guides. Ach, Moment. Dann habe ich mich verguckt.
Ironics. Wäre eigentlich vollkommen egal, wo ich das bestelle.
Okay, der Laden-Sack. Da kann man nicht auswählen, was man für Switches haben will.
Das ist schon mal Müll. Ach so, Taktil. Naja. Otto. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es die noch gibt.
Du magst du Saturen nicht? Ich mag keinen Offline-Laden. Ich mag Leute nicht. Saturen. Bei denen kaufe ich nichts. Kackele an.
Hallo? Gebaited. Was denn jetzt? Habe ich zu viele Tabs auf? You got gebaited.
Ah, mein Browser-Extensions. Blocken das Ganze.
PC-Spezialist Bonn. Aber ich glaube, ich glaube, die kaufe ich mir.
Da weiß ich, dass die Macrosoftware taugt und der Rest passt auch.
Und habt ihr, man kann schön schnell einen AD-AD-Spam machen. Ich spiele zwar keinen Overwatch mehr, aber im Zweifelsfall will ich schnell einen AD-AD-Spam machen.
Wie ist denn so der Vergleich zwischen diesen Tasten, den MX-Speed-Tasten, die ich jetzt habe, und den MX-Brown, die ich auf der Arbeit habe?
Wie ist denn da so der Unterschied? Ich kann mir das immer schlecht vorstellen.
Die Brown-Switches, die ich auf der Arbeit habe, die klicken schon. Also da hört man deutlich Klick beim Unterdrücken.
So, die MX-Speed hört man gar nicht. Guckt, wenn ich die hier drücke.
Das juckt es überhaupt nicht.
Taktil sind, wie du auf der Arbeit hast.
Aber ich hätte gerne lieber wieder welche, die wie MX-Speed sind. Also muss ich doch linear nehmen, oder was?
Dann bestelle ich die jetzt so. Eats. Bam.
Also jetzt nicht im Stream, weil da muss ich mal ein Zeug eingeben.
Lineal ist aber nicht taktil. Ich weiß, dass das nicht taktil ist, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich haben will.
Deswegen kann ich nicht sagen, ich will taktil oder ich will das.
Ich hätte gerne wieder von dem Feeling her sowas wie die MX-Speed-Dinger, die ich daheim habe.
Zum Schreiben macht es mir zwar auf der Ducky-One auf der Arbeit mehr Spaß, aber krach.
Gaming plus Schreiben, die Kombination ist glaube ich das nicht verkehrt.
Wisst ihr was Leute, ich bestelle mir das Teil jetzt einfach. Und guck mal wie das ist.
Ich bestelle mir das einfach und gucke wie das ist.
Und jetzt zum Abschluss, oder ich weiß nicht ob wir fertig sind, mal gucken.
Jetzt gucken wir noch ein Video. Und zwar habe ich gesehen, dass es neue Laura Boards gibt.
Wahrscheinlich war irgendjemand bei dem Stream dabei, wo ich den Controller programmieren wollte für das Grab von meinem Opa.
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Wahrscheinlich denken sich jetzt alle Leute so, alter Max, was willst du?
Also ich habe vor einer Weile einen Stream gemacht, wo ich einen ESP32 programmiert habe.
Mit Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor und niedrigem Eidl Stromverbrauch.
Kann sich vielleicht noch der eine oder andere dran erinnern.
Und das habe ich damals gemacht mit so einem Board, mit so einem Controller und einem Moisture Sensor.
Muss man immer gucken was man da eintippt, mit so einem Ding.
Ziel des Ganzen ist ja gewesen, dass ich das mit einem Laura Chip in das Grab auf dem Friedhof stecke.
Wo das Grab von Opa und Oma ist.
Und ich dann per Laura übertragen lassen kann, also Smart Grave quasi.
Per Laura dann übertragen lassen kann, wie die Bodenfeuchtigkeit auf dem Friedhof ist.
Dass ich weiß, wann ich gießen gehen muss.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch dran.
Das Projekt ist ja nie fertig geworden.
Das Projekt ist ja nie fertig geworden, aber es gibt jetzt neue Laura Boards.
Und da habe ich gesehen, da hat einer meiner Lieblingstechnik YouTube Channels.
Und der meint mit Technik auch wirklich Technik ein Video zugemacht.
Deswegen wollte ich mir mal das Video angucken zu den neuen Laura Boards.
Und wir gucken gleich mal bei AliExpress, was der Grab kostet.
AliExpress GIF.
Das sind die alten Boards.
Ah hier, genau.
So eins will ich haben.
Hast du schon geguckt, Hala?
Ja, aber das Board finde ich interessant.
Das ist der neue Chip.
Und das Board hat glaube ich einen ziemlich geringen Eidelverbrauch.
Was es natürlich für Batterieanwendungen gut macht.
Aber ich will mal gucken, was er dazu sagt.
Ich finde es cool, dass ich nicht der einzige bin, der den Guy with a Swiss Accent guckt.
Was ist denn das für ein Zäppchen?
Sieht aus wie ein Zäppchen, oder?
Was?
Was ist das?
Eine Waterproof Probe?
Was?
Ok, es ist wasserdicht.
Wie funktioniert das mit dem Board?
Kannst du das grob zusammenfassen?
Naja, also, so wie es geplant war und so wie es auch funktioniert hat.
Also der Friedhof ist ungefähr 1,2 Kilometer weg.
Das heißt, wenn ich mit einem Board kommunizieren will, was 1,2 Kilometer weg ist, fällt WLAN
schonmal logischerweise raus.
Also WLAN ist dafür nicht geeignet.
Und es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder man macht das mit Mobilfunk, aber
Mobilfunk kostet und Mobilfunk ist auch nicht so easy da einen ESP anzuschließen, oder
aber man sucht sich was anderes als WLAN, da gibt es LoRa.
LoRa ist quasi ein Protokoll, was ganz, ganz geringe Bandbreite hat, dafür eine ziemlich
hohe Reichweite.
Und ich hab's ausprobiert.
Ich komme von mir daheim 1,2 Kilometer auf den Friedhof und wenn ich das Ding auf das
Grab lege, ich hab doch sogar ein Foto von gemacht, oder?
Ich hab da doch sogar ein Foto von gemacht.
Fotos.
Ich poste immer so viele Fotos, da findet man jetzt wahrscheinlich nix.
Das war letzt Jahr Agent One.
Ich suche hier Max, Max, WS, Friedhof, äh, Friedhof?
Grab?
Okay, keine Ahnung, ich find's jetzt nicht.
Zumindest hab ich dann hier unterm Dach einen Controller stehen mit Antenne und am Grab
hab ich dann nen Sensor mit Bodenfeuchtigkeit und so nem Controller und der schickt quasi
dann alle vier Stunden die Bodenfeuchtigkeit vom Friedhof zu mir heim.
In dem Bereich gibt's aber, LoRa ist 864, 868, doch, doch, das kann man verwenden, überhaupt
848 Megahertz.
Ich glaub in die EU kann man auch 433 verwenden.
Ich hab, ich hab ein paar LoRa Module ausprobiert, 433 und 868, das hier ist glaub ich für,
für Asien, ähm, ähm, bei mir funktioniert 868 besser, wobei theoretisch ja 433 besser
durch Mauern gehen müsste, aber 868 funktioniert bei mir am besten.
Und wenn ich sage, das Ding hat langsame Datenübertragungsraten, das hat wirklich
langsame Datenübertragungsraten.
Ja, das betreib ich mit, das betreib ich da mit nem Akku.
Ich hab's aber nie final getestet, das, das, das, das was ich getestet hab, ich hab's
bei mir im Hof in die, in der Erde verbuttelt und dort Sachen senden lassen.
Ähm, ach der Akku hält ne ganze Weile.
Ich kann, ich kann dir sagen wie lang der Akku hält, ähm, Battery Calculator.
So, noch mal zwei Sekunden, Code Execution, Sleep Time, ähm, was sind das, Sleep Time
Sekunden, ähm, Seconds, vier, vier Stunden zu Sekunden, so, ähm, Power Consumption
During Code Execution, ja, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie so, ähm, in Sleep Mode haben wir
micro Ampere, ich sag jetzt mal so neun ungefähr, äh, den 1200er Akku und machen wir hier 20.
So, das ist optimal Werte, das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht, aber so ungefähr kann man
sich das ganze vorstellen, also die Batterie wird dann ungefähr so, sagen wir mal zwei,
drei Jahre halten.
Ihr, ich sag mal so, wenn's ne Jahr hält, bin ich schon froh.
Ne, ich denk mal ein Jahr wird's ungefähr halten.
Ich denk mal ungefähr ein Jahr wird die Batterie halten, wenn alles gut läuft.
Was für ne Batterie ist das, ne, so ne ganz normale, so eine, sowas da.
Ich hab's mir mit Solarzellen überlegt, aber Solarzellen ist noch mal ne ganz eigene
Herausforderung.
Zumal die Solarzellen irgendwo hinmussen und ich will keine, ich will ja, dass man an dem
Grab nix sieht.
Erstens, weil sogar da Leute was klauen und zweitens, weil es halt auch nicht schön aussieht,
wenn da ne Solarzelle auf dem Grab liegt.
Ich mein, es wär, es wär advanced, ja, aber es sieht ein bisschen doof aus, wenn auf dem
Grab ne Solarzelle liegt, zumal das was garantiert jemand klaut.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile wird sogar auf dem Friedhof Zeug geklaut.
Heascun haben sie mir schon geklaut, auf dem Friedhof.
Und wahrscheinlich Stryker regt sich da auch jemand auf.
Warum man das auf dem Grab haben muss, hab ich doch grad gesagt, dass man die Bodenfeuchtigkeit,
die, ähm, wie viel Wasser im Boden ist, übertragen kann.
Dass ich weiß, wann ich wieder gießen gehen muss.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich big brain.
Ich guck danach, wie die Bodenfeuchtigkeit ist.
Wenn die Bodenfeuchtigkeit quasi unter nem gewissen Level ist, ich könnt's ja noch mehr
big brain machen.
Ich hab ja die, ich hab ja gar nicht so die, ähm, komplette high IQ Sache programmiert.
Ich hätt es ja auch so machen können, dass das Ding nur den, also dass das Ding alle
vier Stunden aufwacht aus dem Deep Sleep.
Luft, äh, Boden, doch hab ich, hab ich gemacht, hab ich gemacht.
Ähm, Bodenfeuchtigkeit misst und erst wenn die Abweichung größer ist und unter nem gewissen
Level hat, nur dann schickt er was.
Was nämlich dazu führt, dass der Energieverbrauch noch viel geringer ist, weil das Einzige,
wo das Ding richtig viel Energie verbraucht ist, wenn er die Sachen schickt.
Ähm, passt, passt in dieses Ding das Board rein oder was soll das sein, wenn's fertig
ist.
Das ist einfach nur ne Kapsel, wo man nen Sensor rein machen kann, ja gut.
Ähm, das brauch ich nicht wirklich.
Max FPS Stato, hast du meinen Tweet gefunden?
Nee, das ist das Falsche.
Das ist, wo ich ein bisschen mit ESPN auch rumgespielt hab.
Aber so ungefähr zu dieser Zeit müsste das gewesen sein, wo ich das mit dem Friedhof gepostet
hab.
Aber muss das jetzt nicht suchen.
So, und da gibt's jetzt neue Boards, die wohl ziemlich gut sein sollen.
Deswegen wollte ich mir das Video mal angucken von ihm, was er, was er nach so, so zu erzählen
hat.
Today we will look at a completely new LoRa Board, a new LoRa chip and a new microprocessor.
Is it the best LoRa Board ever?
And what about the new LoRa chip?
Let's have a closer look.
Good to you tubers, here is the guy with the Swiss accent, with a new episode and fresh
ideas around sensors and microcontrollers.
Remember, if you subscribe, you will always sit in the first row.
Das erinnert mich immer an so, mit dem zweiten sieht man besser.
You still have one, of course.
Earlier this year, they finally add new LoRa chips.
Ich will eigentlich nur Stromverbrauch wissen.
Also was macht er?
New and old chips, ganz ehrlich, solange die neuen nicht schlechter sind als die alten,
juckt mich das nicht.
Modules, Arduino IDE Support ist mir auch relativ egal.
Man kriegt's schon garantiert, man kriegt's irgendwie zum Laufen.
Hier, Power, Output, Power Consumption.
Output, während er überträgt, ist nicht so wichtig, weil das Übertragen dauert zwei
Sekunden oder so.
Power Consumption.
Ich hab die Logitech noch nicht bestellt, nee.
Zeig mal Power Consumption, wir gucken das gar nicht in 1.
Koffer wirklich, wir springen vor zu Power Consumption.
Ah, hier.
Ja, weil die Hersteller low brain sind und immer den USB-Anschluss nicht abschalten.
Oh, guck mal, das hat sogar nen Solar Input.
Das ist ein cooles Board.
Und wo macht man die Batterie dran?
Hat das einen Anschluss für eine Batterie?
Hat das einen Batterieanschluss?
Oh.
Ich seh jetzt keinen, wenn ich ehrlich bin, aber vielleicht unten.
Ach, da.
Ah, hätt ich mal gewartet, da zeigt das ja.
Was es einem bringt, dass ich weiß wann ich gießen gehen muss.
Ja, die Hand ist geil, ne.
Okay, zeig ich mal.
Ja, der Verbrauch ist wurscht, ich muss wissen was das Ding Eidl verbraucht.
Steckt der Chip direkt in der Erde?
Ne, in einer IP67-Box.
Das Einzige was direkt im Boden steckt ist der Sensor.
Ja, das ist mir egal, was ist der Eidl-Verbrauch?
Was?
9.6, also 10, 10 µA.
Oh, das ist richtig gut.
Das ist richtig gut.
Das ist fast so wenig, oder es ist sogar, das ist genauso wenig wie der Fire Beetle Verbrauch.
10 µA, das ist nix.
Der hält das Ding, der hält das Ding locker an der Batterie.
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
Das ist richtig gut.
Okay, bestellen, muss ich auch noch bestellen, muss ich mir speichern.
Okay, diese komische Sensor-Pille, Sensor-Zäpfchen brauche ich nicht.
Ein Jahr locker hält das Ding im Jahr.
An einer 1200, an so einem Ding da.
Ist ein Raspberry Pi Zero nicht billiger?
Raspberry Pi Zero ist, ich glaube, ähnlich teuer, aber, ne teurer, aber nicht wirklich viel,
aber hat riesen Nachteile gegenüber so einem ESP32.
Der Stromverbrauch ist einfach, vor allem Eidl, einfach viel, viel geringer.
So ein Raspberry Pi kannst du vielleicht, sagen wir mal so, kannst, ich schätze,
ist über den Daumen gepilet, ja, über den Daumen gepilet.
Sag ich mal ungefähr, kannst du so ein Raspberry, kannst du an so einem Ding 5-6 Stunden betreiben,
wahrscheinlich länger, ich sag jetzt einfach mal, sagen wir mal, 10 Stunden, 10 Stunden,
einfach 5, 6, 7, 8, schwierig zu schätzen, aber sagen wir, runden wir mal auf,
sagen wir, du kannst so einen Raspberry einen Tag oder vielleicht sogar zwei Tage an so einer Batterie betreiben.
Ich weiß nicht, was da so standardmäßig Eidl braucht, aber dann ist Schluss.
Wohingegen, du einen ESP, in dem Fall einen ESP32, wenn der ordentlich gebaut ist, das Board,
sodass der in Deep Sleep gehen kann und dann alles ausschaltet, mal ein Jahr an der Batterie hängen lassen kannst.
Wie ist eben der andere YouTube-Channel, Andreas Spieß, heißt der.
Also ein Raspberry Pi und sowohl der Zero, das sind beides tolle Geräte für ihren Anwendungszweck,
aber für Batteriebetrieb sind die beiden nix.
So, so ein Ding muss ich mir bestellen. Was kostet denn hier das Board jetzt?
365?
Das check ich immer bei AliExpress nicht.
Kostet, kostet die Kapsel, kostet die Kapsel jetzt 15 Euro oder was?
What?
Ich will eigentlich, will ich das Board haben?
Ah, hier ist das Board.
1370.
Was ist unsere Empfehlung für Sie?
Alter, AliExpress machst du doch nicht so kompliziert.
Ich brauche nicht 863 bis 915, ich brauche 868 Megahertz, nicht irgendwie random irgendwas.
Was? Hallo? Was? Ich brauche, ah, AliExpress, please. Come on, brah.
Der kann bestimmt beide.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Die können eigentlich nicht beide, zumindest konnten das die alten Chips nicht.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel, weil ja auch die ganze Antennengeschichte und so,
also entweder haben die einfach den gleichen Chip zweimal reingebaut.
Farbe? Wo steht Farbe? Ich sehe keine Farbe.
Und warum, warum kann man das überhaupt hier nochmal auswählen?
Ja, vielleicht kann er wirklich beides.
Vielleicht kann er echt beides.
Das verwirrt mich, dass es hier zweimal das gleiche gibt.
ASR 650, ASR 6000, oh Gott, die Bezeichnung wieder.
Vor allem warum heißt das den XSX1262? Der Alte hieß SX1272.
Was, Farbe? Ach hier, ja ich weiß, das sind die einzelnen Sachen, die hier drin sind.
Also das sind die ganzen unterschiedlichen Artikel.
Das verwirrt mich mal wieder bei AliExpress.
Also ich vermute mal, dass ich den da haben will.
Was sich preislich zwar nicht so ganz deckt, aber ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so checke,
wo jetzt der Unterschied ist.
DevPort 433, DevPort 868 und das ist...
Ok Leute, AliExpress, was auch immer.
Aber so einen Teil werde ich mir auf jeden Fall noch bestellen.
Das ist sehr nice.
Da kann ich endlich mal mein Smart Grave Projekt abschließen.
Wozu ich mir jetzt allerdings für 15 Euro so ein Zäpfchen kaufen soll,
erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht.
Ist das groß genug, dass hier auch der Controller reinpasst?
Oder passt hier nur der Lora-Sensor rein?
Also die AliExpress-Bilder sind wieder absolut Big Brain, muss man sagen.
Huge Brain.
Das muss ich mir mal in Ruhe angucken, bevor ich da was bestelle, sonst ist es wieder RIP.
Das ist der gleiche Shop, beides.
Hau mal den Darkreader rein.
Das ist ja die hässlichste Lora-Antenne je ever.
Ahja, wurscht, das guck ich mir mal in Ruhe an.
Aber da muss ich mal...
Wann ist es lieferbar?
23.01., 23.01.
Was haben wir sonst noch so für Sachen?
DHL, 24 Euro.
Mhm, ist klar.
E-Paket mit Tracking-Number.
AliExpress Premium Shipping, einfach für 19 Euro.
Vielleicht ist der Controller dabei.
Ich hab's auch gesehen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass der Controller dabei ist.
Ich glaube, bei der Capsule ist nur der Lora-Chip dabei.
Also nur der da.
Oder was auch immer.
Ich check's ehrlich gesagt grad nicht so genau.
Aber werde ich mir bestellen.
Little Honey Play With Baby.
Ja, Play With Baby ist eindeutig so eine Metallspinne.
Ist schon das Beste, um mit Babys zu spielen, oder?
So eine Metallspinne.
Oh, Little Honey, so ein Metallskorpion?
Die Chinesen, oder?
E-Sports!
Oh, wir gucken mal, was es bei AliExpress unter E-Sports gibt.
Das ist jetzt E-Sports?
Ein Lora-Gateway.
Hohe Qualität.
Stillruhige 120mm PC-Fan.
Batterien.
Abdichtungskabel, Abdichtungsdinger.
Controller, Ladegerät, Dock.
Das ist ja richtig E-Sports.
Moment.
Wie viel kostet der Lüfter?
Wartet mal.
Ah, das ist Jebait.
Das ist Jebait.
Das ist Lockangebot, dass man sich neu registriert.
Sobald ich mich einlocke, geht das nicht mehr.
Das ist Jebait.
Komplett Jebait.
Also man muss schon sagen,
es ist äußerst E-Sport-mäßig, was man hier bei AliExpress unter E-Sport kaufen kann.
Es ist auch übrigens keine Switch, sondern nur eine Hülle.
Oh Leute, 22 Uhr.
Gleich wird gepennt.
Aber AliExpress ist immer so schön billig alles.
Und ich habe schon lange nichts mal bei AliExpress bestellt.
Das wird mal wieder Zeit.
Das ist wieder so ein 1 Cent-Ding.
Top-Cack, guck mal hier.
Top-Cack USB-Halter.
Doch, das ist E-Sports, wenn man da draufklickt.
Guck hier.
E-Sports.
Das ist der typische AliExpress Jebait.
Wir haben selten Sachen, was mit dem zu tun, wo man draufklickt.
Das ist normal.
AliExpress, das ist Jebait in Perfektion an vielen Stellen.
Die schreiben immer andere Sachen hin, als das dahinter ist.
Die schreiben das hin, was dich dazu bringt, draufzuklicken.
Ich meine, sonderlich E-Sport ist das Ganze jetzt ja nicht.
Das ist eher abhängig von dem, was ich mir schon angeguckt habe.
Eatshare.
Brauche für seine Playstation 5 einen extra Fan.
Das ist alles reichlich sinnloses Zeug, was man da kaufen kann.
Ganz viele Kabelabdichtungs-Dinger.
Also jede Menge Lampen-Halterungen bzw. Mikrofon, Pop-Schutz-Halterungen,
HDMI-Kabel, Controller-Ladestationen, Batterien
und Zeug, was ich nicht brauche.
Oh, Huge-USB-Sticks, Leute, da sind sie wieder.
Ich suche heute nicht nach Huge-USB-Sticks.
Kein Bock auf Onkartos.
Würdest du mir VS Code für Flutter empfehlen?
Ich hatte bis jetzt immer Software von JetBrains.
Ich kann jetzt zu Flutter nichts empfehlen,
weil ich Flutter selbst nur ganz wenig verwendet habe.
Ich weiß nicht, was die beste Idee für Flutter ist.
Weil wenn man nach Huge-USB-Sticks ist,
man irgendwelche Sexspielzeuge findet bei AliExpress.
Was auch immer das mit USB-Sticks zu tun hat, das weiß nur AliExpress.
Der Schneemann-CPU-Cooler.
Ah, der ist es also.
So der chinesische Noctua-Fake.
Die hier alles andrehen wollen.
Also, dass ich Kabeldichtungen brauche,
scheint ganz hoch im Kurs zu stehen.
Ich brauche unbedingt Kabeldichtungen.
Ganz ultra wichtig Kabeldichtungen brauche ich unbedingt.
Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Wie viele Kabel ich abdichten muss,
das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was meinen die, wie viele Kabel ich habe?
Max, ich hoffe, dass morgen die Streams besser laufen beim 36.
Äh, äh, äh, äh, liefen die heute schlecht?
Äh, IntelliJ würde ich nehmen.
Vor allem, wenn du schon immer Jetplanes Zeug verwendet hast.
Schlecht bis gar nicht.
Na gut, da gucken wir...
Also den Watt gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall an vom Bahnmining.
Den Watt gucken wir uns an.
Den Vortrag bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt.
Bester Treffer.
Für was Bester Treffer?
Für Bikinis.
Wo kann man die CCC Geschichten sehen?
Einfach mal den auf der Seite.
Muss man Google anschmeißen.
Sie mögen mir der für Zeug verkaufen wollen.
Bei Aliexpress, der Wahnsinn.
Ich scroll hier besser nicht so weit.
Man weiß nie, was da drin ist.
Okay Leute, ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Und zumindest gehe ich off.
Äh, warum habe ich denn das immer noch auf?
Gibt es morgen Aufwachstream?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Muss ich mal morgen früh gucken.
Kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Moin Alex.
Du bist leider ein bisschen spät.
Muss jetzt weg.
Also Leute.
Rush B.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Bis denn.
Machts gut.
Tschüss.